this is jocko podcast number 257 with
echo charles and me
jocko willink good evening echo
the president of the united states of
america takes pleasure in presenting the
silver star to sergeant first class
ryan michael hendrickson united states
army for exceptional gallantry in the
face of the
enemies of the united states of america
with exceptional
valorous conduct as the engineer
sergeant
of special operational detachment bravo
sfodb7220
advanced operations based north special
operations task force afghanistan
on 23 february 2016 during
operation freedoms sentinel in support
of resolute support
mission four on 23 february 2016
members of the fifth eighth and tenth
special operations
kandak tactically advised by
sfoda7223 and
sfodb7220
conducted clearing operations in order
to deny a known
taliban safe haven sergeant first class
hendrickson
led a team of national mine reduction
group
nmrg soldiers ahead of the main effort
to clear
routes of improvised explosive devices
ieds clearing 15 ieds in the process
while conducting movement to the first
compound of interest
a member of this element struck a
tripwire
the element immediately took cover
however there was no detonation
sergeant first class hendrickson's team
was then immediately ambushed by heavy
enemy machine gun small arms and rpg
fire
from approximately 15 meters away
sergeant first class hendrickson
immediately directed
his nmrg team to place suppressive fires
on the enemy while providing detailed
terminal attack guidance
which enabled an f-16 close air support
platform
to conduct a strike on fortified enemy
fighting positions
danger close to his position
sergeant first class hendrickson
assessed that his element needed to
maneuver away from the enemy's position
to ensure
the safety safety of his nmrg
members he quickly led the element to
bound back to a friendly position
by creating additional distance between
his team and the enemy
air assets were able to successfully
neutralize the enemy
during a second air strike
after the smoke cleared following
air-to-ground engagements
sergeant first class hendrickson
immediately began clearing a path for
friendly forces
by leading his team to clear several
complex ieds
designed to target friendly dismounted
elements
during exfiltration the element was
re-engaged by heavy and effective
enemy pkm rpg sniper and mortar fire
which resulted in multiple u.s and
partner force casualties
sergeant first class hendrickson
directed afghan commandos
who were pinned down and separated from
the main element to maneuver
to and gain cover behind his position
under heavy enemy fire sergeant first
class hendrickson directed friendly
elements to a nearby compound
where the casualty collection point ccp
was established
after conducting headcount sergeant
first class hendrickson realized that
two
partner first members were missing
sergeant first class hendrickson
organized a team to locate and recover
the separated and potentially wounded
friendly forces
sergeant first class hendrickson had to
be held back numerous times while air
support conducted additional attacks on
enemy positions once the air-to-ground
engagements were complete sergeant first
class hendrickson
selflessly maneuvered the recovery team
under enemy small arms fire to retrieve
the missing
friendlies upon reaching the two missing
soldiers
they discovered that the soldiers had
been mortally wounded
sergeant first class hendrickson then
utilized a ladder as a litter to help
carry the wounded soldiers
to the ccp while his element continued
to engage enemy forces with suppressive
fires
sergeant first class hendrickson's
actions prevented the taliban
forces from recovering the bodies of
friendly forces
which ensured all partner force members
were accounted for
leaving no one behind
sergeant first class hendrickson's
actions are in keeping with the finest
traditions of military heroism
and reflect distinct credit upon himself
the special operations task force
afghanistan the north atlantic treaty
organization
special operation component command
afghanistan
special operations joint task force
and the united states
army
so obviously that is a
silver star citation
from an incredibly hard mission and this
particular individual this special
forces
soldier ryan hendrickson
he had already been through hell
just to get on that mission
and luckily for us he has written a book
about his experiences
which is called tip of the spear and it
is an honor to have him with us here
tonight
to share his story ryan
that was a doozy of a mission thanks for
coming on man
i really appreciate you guys having me
on here yeah that was
this is awesome well it's good to meet
you and um
we'll dive into that some of the details
around that what you did there because
really that's you know like i said you
already been through a hell of a lot
just to be on that mission in the first
place
you've been well we'll get there um
but yeah let's let's start at the
beginning and and you know i i read your
book
and uh it's called tip of the spear the
incredible story of an
injured green beret's return to battle
and i always like to start at the
beginning so
let's start the beginning let's see what
made ryan hendrickson
so you start off here in the book i grew
up in the unincorporated california
town of fall river mills nestled between
the sierra nevada
and cascade mountain ranges in rugged
shasta county
and then you and i always have to say
this i have to jump around in the book
i'm not going to read the whole book
you have to buy the book if you want to
get the whole story but i'll i'll fast
forward through a bunch of the
highlights
this is always a good way to start life
pretty much sucked
because my mother who delivered my
sister and me into this world was hooked
on drugs and alcohol
dad sent her packing my dad was a
vietnam vet who did two tours as an
aviation crew chief
chief before returning to the pacific
northwest and eventually northern
california
following his honorable discharge from
the u.s army during the vietnam war my
dad's primary air
aircraft was the dh3 otter with the 54th
aviation
out of vang tao but he constantly found
himself flying into combat
in a huey military helicopter formerly
known
as the bell uh-1 it was in a huey
that my father experienced the true
horror of war as
an m60 door gunner using the deadly
firepower at his fingertips to rain down
death on nva troops and viet cong
so your dad was in nam how many years
did he do did he do like the two years
like hey i was in vietnam i did two
years and got out are you staying longer
what do you do
well yeah he actually uh he actually did
two tours in vietnam
so total of four years in the army but
he did uh two back to
back-to-back tours in vietnam as in two
years straight
dang yeah well there was a there was a
break because he came back for r
r and then went back so you know kind of
a
little break but but yeah he did he did
his two tours over there and and
what what do you know anything about his
decision-making process on that
his uh so what we have talked about his
decision behind
wanting to do multiple tours in vietnam
is number one he loved the people
um and uh number two it's
it it's combat and combat's addicting
extremely
dangerously addicting and that was kind
of
when he was over there he's like hey i
can go back to wherever
northern california or oregon or i can
sit here and just keep getting after it
yep and the choice was pretty obvious
for how old was he
uh he left out of high school he
volunteered for the army i know high
school which uh
what do you know what year it was 1966.
oh dang i think yeah around in there
but then he got out so he did two tours
two years straight
with a little break do you know why he
got out
um i'm not extremely sure the
decision-making process behind him
getting out i just
as he told me you know back in those
days um being in the military wasn't
like it is today and so
um you know getting out and moving on
with your life or whatnot like that that
it's just the military wasn't popular at
the time
um it wasn't a prestigious thing for
you know like today um us serving
um it's you know it means something and
back then it's
he's like wow yeah well if he went in in
66 so he
needed two tours and nom pro so he's
we're talking yeah this is 1968
1969. the war is freaking everyone's
against it
um you guys moved around a bunch um
reading uh you you say this about your
dad before wendy and that's your sister
yes
before wendy and i came in the world
though my dad was a guy who liked his
beer
he'd get drunk and if you happen to
cross paths with him in the wrong way
you would most likely be at the losing
end of a fist fight
he worked hard logging putting in crazy
12-hour days but he partied even harder
when the logging industry was booming
and money was good coming in he was
blowing
a healthy portion of his dough on booze
and you go into some detail here he was
just sort of blazing a past
of destruction um
one night he's like drunk and
basically feels like his life is kind of
going nowhere yep and he's
well i i'll go to the book here while
driving in his drunken stupor my father
thought about what his life had become
his options had slowly dwindled down
over the years with no hope and no
future he believed he was facing his
last choice to end it all dad pulled his
truck
in front of uncle steve's house right as
he shifted into park
a man appeared in front of the house and
walked up to the driver's side window
dad hadn't seen him and seen him leave
the house so he didn't know
how or why this man had approached his
car my uncle lived in the middle of
nowhere
larry hendrickson the middle-aged man
dressed conservatively had
a smile on his face my father had never
seen this man in his life
how do you know my name he asked the man
ignored the question
larry you're out of chances aren't you
he asked
this time my father was too stunned to
answer it doesn't have to be that way
the man continued
jesus has a better plan for you and your
life
in front of my uncle's house that night
my father found god
after that his hellion days slowed to a
trickle
that didn't mean he didn't get pissed
off at the cards he was dealt in life
especially after he had just polished
off another six-pack
but my father like everyone else i've
met including myself was on a journey
so that sounds like almost a mystical
situation
like where'd this dude come from yeah so
talking out or talking it out with my
dad and it's one of the most powerful
stories
um but yeah he was so
he threw the truck in the park and he
was going to bring my sister and i
to my uncle's house tell my uncle to
take care of us
then he was going to go shoot himself in
the head and that's
i i don't know i mean you know i am
religious
and i believe you know i believe that
god has a plan for everybody
um and i that that was just the plan
did this guy did we ever see this guy
again
i don't think he we ever did i i was
young
so but i don't think my dad ever did now
crazy yeah um
so you guys move around uh for a while
you say we lived out
it we lived out in the woods in a house
that had no running water due to damaged
pipes and limited electricity
so the place was cheap your dad got hurt
and then he gets healed up
and and you say it was clear that he
couldn't even afford a home with running
water or steady electricity
his only option was to have us move in
with his mother
who lived in colton oregon won a 100
miles to the south
colton was even smaller than birkenfield
but my grandmother could help provide
the necessities of life while my father
got under his feet and attended a bible
college
he wanted to become a preacher fast
forward a little bit after my father got
ordained as a preacher
his first pastorate was at a small
church in lincoln city on the central
oregon coast
he seemed happy and we as a family were
happy
although we were still poor it didn't
matter much because life was good my dad
didn't
my dad being a preacher didn't lift us
out of poverty actually just the
opposite happened
we had to live in a tent for several
months while we waited to move
into the upstairs of the parsonage
tent living wasn't bad but it did get
embarrassing when other kids saw our
living conditions and teased me at
school
all right let's get down to brass tacks
how big of a tent was this tent
um i would say uh alaskan tint
afghan alaskan tent and now i kind of
feel bad about writing that in there
because
um i've definitely lived in an alaskan
tent with about 15 other dudes
and so we actually had it pretty nice
yeah right on well that's a positive
attitude man
i like it um
you continue on here after the tiny
church in lincoln city couldn't afford
to keep its doors open we were forced to
pack up and move again
this time we settled in the sleepy
logging town of
lowell oregon 20 miles southeast of
eugene and populated with 1 000
residents
my dad did his best to keep us in one
spot until i could finish high school
and move on with my life i guess having
four years in one place is why
i say that lowell is my hometown
i was always active as a kid preferring
to wander around the foothills
of the cascade mountains or play sports
rather than sitting on my butt watching
movies or doing nothing
i'm sure i was hell for my dad to raise
but he instilled in me the idea that i
should set the rules for my life not let
life
set rules for me at lowell high i gave
everything i had to our football and
wrestling programs
i was never the most talented athlete
but every coach said i was the toughest
kid they'd ever trained
that was when i first heard the saying
that boy's too stupid to quit
a backhanded compliment for sure but i
wore it like a badge of honor
uh how good were you at wrestling um i
was
mediocre and so but i did you start
wrestling
in in high school or did you wrestle
before that uh eighth grade is when i
started yeah
so i so you're going against kids that
were wrestling since they were
whatever yeah first grade kindergarten
yep yeah i was never a rock star at it
or anything like that but
i picked it up quickly and um and i just
kind of
i don't know it was a wrestling night in
my mind
i know um people will have their own
opinions about it but
it's probably one of the toughest um i
guess
sports out there as far as physical
fitness endurance and whatnot and that
also leads into
you know um jujitsu and greco-roman and
freestyle and whatnot
but um it also what it did for me was it
kind of
i i already had that work ethic but it
kind of like
i mean you have to get tough or you're
just going to get slaughtered on the mat
and that's embarrassing because
i've had it happen before what weight
did you wrestle at
um so i wrestled i started off at
1 120
whatever it was 120 20 whatever yeah
yeah and then
my senior year um i cut weight down to
which um was yeah pretty hard but i was
running from the 151 weight class
because the kid there was just
a beast and so i cut weight down to 142
basically running from somebody
and uh went to state and then you know
did okay okay well damn if you went to
state
in oregon that's freaking legit yeah it
was during the
gutches period and stuff like that so um
we
we had a pretty organ uh was nationally
known for wrestling with you know like
the gutchest brothers and whatnot
but that's awesome man um
here's a little story one day as we were
kicking around
my future you're talking about your dad
he told me a story
there were two old men sitting on their
porches staring out into the abyss
they didn't know each other but they had
one thing in common
they were waiting on death i leaned in
closer dad could always tell a good
story but this was different he meant
business
one old man was miserable he had let
life's chances passing by and now
thoughts of opportunities long gone were
replaced
with haunted ideas of what could have
been
the other old man was totally fulfilled
by the life he had lived
he had done everything there was to do
and now he could sit back and relish his
golden
moments and wonderful memories because
he had lived life
to the fullest so there you go son
i wish i would have done this or that
statements are a prison of misery for
the mind
you want to go through life and be
perfectly content with the life you've
lived
you want to do everything there is to be
done right or wrong
you do it and never regret a decision
you made
this from a man who'd been off to war
fought for his life
seen the world given life taken life
loved and had his heart broken
he had made mistakes taking chances and
failed and succeeded many times
good or bad i can sit back and reminisce
on my life and feel good about it he
said
when god tells me it's my time to go
home i will leave this earth fulfilled
because i've done it all and i want you
to feel the same way
so let me leave you with this thought
what kind of old man do you want to be
son
freaking good guidance from the from
from pops yep
yeah that's um that is pretty much that
guidance right there is
pretty much led you know half of the
the decisions i've made in my life
whether or not i look back and i'm like
wow i can't believe i'm alive from that
um most of what he said right there is
the reason why
you know i can look back and like wow
that was i was really dumb let's try
this again
so and that's sort of what made you guys
start talking about you going in the
military mm-hmm
i know you you checked with an army
recruiter
um you didn't even you didn't even think
about the navy
no at first
so the uh basically how it went down was
uh my
my teachers basically said hey you'll
graduate if you join the military
you are you are dum-dum like you need to
go do something that the military will
force you to
so all right so the air force they
looked at my test scores and they're
like
no sorry man you're you're real cute but
no
um the uh the army they actually didn't
in the mid 90s
they didn't need anybody it was crazy so
they had like patriot missile program
and it was like a six-month wait to get
in
and then the marines came in and that
guy was so
angry and mean and i was like man you're
scary i'm like
i don't want to be a marine you're
scaring me and then so the navy
recruiter
i mean he might as well had on like a
hawaiian t-shirt or whatnot but
you know you want to you want to be an
f-14 tomcat pilot like
tom cruise like yeah you want to be a
navy seal like charlie sheens
yeah you want to go to exotic ports and
see exotic women and yeah he goes cool
man sign here
it's like oh right yeah i didn't i
didn't fly an f-14
that as a neat one oh man
so so then you went to boot camp and
look there's so much
you cover the stuff in the book which is
which is cool um
but i'm going to jump through jump past
some of that stuff
you go on here you finally get to see
being on board a ship with 900 other
sailors and marines all mailing this
deployment was a major culture shock and
not for the faint of heart
especially for low enlisted sailors like
me working 16-hour days and doing
maintenance duties like keeping the deck
department
and equipment in good condition loading
and unloading cargo shining brass
busting rust because of salt water and
painting bulkheads
walls and passageways the same
battleship gray
sucked what little free time i had was
spending my coffin rack
trying to get some much-needed sleep
tell us about a coffin rack what's that
all about
coffin racks yes um so when people talk
about quality of life in the military
i just say if you've never lived on a
ship that was commissioned in the 60s
um then i i don't think you really
understand what
bad quality life is so what was worse
the tent that you lived in or a ship
board oh [ __ ]
oh by far yeah and the marines had it
even worse oh yeah
they were i think they were stuck like
six high down in the marine birthing
base or five high
yeah well i did two deployments on
amphib ships
and both of them were built in like 1960
something like that and they were built
to transport
troops over to the southeast asia
yeah and so you were supposed to be on
them when they originally built they're
supposed to put marines on there for
whatever a four-week
trip and then you'd get off and go do
your work well by the time the 90s
rolled around like what you're talking
about here
we were going on six six month
deployments yeah and and yes i
stayed in the as a seal was staying in
the birthing where where the
marines stayed and so yeah there would
be david we we literally had the old
school
canvas racks the canvas strung between
metal pipes
yeah and then a little cheap freaking
mattress on top of that
and yeah it was just and either be four
or five high
i think usually we would kind of adjust
our our living space
as seals we'd kind of like yeah we'd do
some work in there
so maybe it wouldn't be quite as bad but
uh get some
coffin rack sorry i cut you off no
people yeah people don't understand but
your
your entire life so i've done um i was
on you know the uss report which was
lpd12 and fib boiler super old
and then um you know the guam i did some
time on that and then the camden
well the camden was commissioned in the
70s so it was
super it was just this great upgrade um
but yeah the shreveport we we were in
the persian gulf
probably 10 months in 98
and um and then yeah it's your coffin
rack
like you have that thin mattress and
then
you open up the what the mattress sits
on is basically a lid
that you open up and now you have um
your your area your where your clothes
go
and you know everything else and it's
just this tiny
like it it's it's a coffin but even a
coffin has more depth than
a coffin rack does on board a ship and
so
yeah that's that's your entire life and
when you're in deck division
and you're lower enlisted i mean we were
stacked four high and
and so it was and then you got you know
you have your little uh
curtain close the curtain and you know
try and get some sleep or whatnot and
maybe kick the rack of the guy next to
you and he's
being too louder so
but you know you know you know all about
it yeah no it's uh
it's that's what's always surprising is
you know when guys are going through
seal training
and you know even if you even if you
just hear about that you think well i
don't that doesn't sound like a good
deal i might be wet cold and sandy right
now but
that sounds like maybe i don't want to
go do that
uh this was i thought this was
interesting so
fast forward a little bit at the time
the uss cole was bombed
i was on board my second ship the uss
camden we were then
12 hours of yemen when the distress
calls came out
we sailed full steam ahead through the
straits of hormuz
and along the uss along with the uss
donald cook
we would be the first american military
personnel to arrive and assist
the coal crew in saving the ship and
pulling bodies from the wreckage
i'll never forget the smell of burning
human flesh when i stepped on board the
coal
for the next week we teamed up with coal
crew members to keep the ship from
sinking
and recovered the remains of all 17
heroes killed that day
i was i had witnessed the first salvo in
what would become known
as the war on terror and our rescue and
recovery effort with the uss cole would
impact my life in the years to come
yeah you you definitely being on a navy
ship you feel
very untouchable by the enemy for sure
and especially in the 90s so that must
have been a shocker
i mean it was a shocker for the world
but for you to actually go there that's
crazy yeah
seeing that i remember when we were on
the um
uh we call them liberty boats but you
know there were the barges taking us
over
over to uh the uh coal and just looking
at that massive hole
in the side of it that had just been
blown in there about 18
hours prior it was um yeah it's pretty
intense
it's you know you go from untouchable to
all of a sudden
you you can be touched and so and yeah
it would set the path for
you know my you know basically what i
did in special operations and whatnot as
a green beret
and the enemy trying to kill me and that
you know the um
the zip and the crack and and you're not
untouchable anymore and so yeah but that
was the first
first little idea i got of what of wow
you know people
they they do want to kill you yeah and
that's a weird feeling
yeah yeah it takes a little getting used
to
uh spring in 2001 you get out
you get out of the navy um you got
married and
again there's all kinds of good this is
good some good life lessons learned in
this book
very good life lessons in this book uh
so you get married
you get out of the navy you actually
married a girl that was in the army
and so you get out you try a bunch of
different jobs you end up as a bartender
um which echo supports
september 11th happens and now
you're feeling like you know hey
maybe i want to go do something in the
meantime
i got to read this little section one
day in early 2002 i received
a phone call out of the blue hi is this
ryan hendrickson
yes who's this it's your big sister
chris remember me
barely i thought our family had been
separated when i was still in diapers i
had two
older half sisters paula was five years
old and chris was eight
years older i also had a half brother
who was 10 years older
than me and lived with us periodically
his name was robbie
both my dad and his first wife were
heavy drinkers one night she swept up my
older siblings and disappeared i had
memories of them
but i was so young i didn't really have
a grasp of what had happened or who they
were
and now this phone call came out of the
blue so that's that's kind of crazy
yeah yeah that was uh that was something
else and she wanted to contact me
because she she basically said like you
won't remember
all the bad stuff so i'm going to start
off with you but it was when um
is when that uh what is it not ancestry
dna but
whenever they're building your family
trees yeah like the genealogy type thing
yeah so that's actually when everyone
you know started getting connected back
again and and um it was
it was yeah it was it was crazy but my
dad and i we made a trip down to new
mexico to see him
and that was the first time he saw his
kids in years
years since you know um
and then we just you know we started
kind of building the bridges back and
you know i learned i learned just how uh
you know my dad like he he lived a hard
life
you know and so i heard some of those
stories
and um but that's that's the one thing
that
you know the people that are out there
and they say ah you know people people
never change
are you you're not gonna change once
you're once a loser always lose or
something like that
and now you're looking at my dad and i
could be like i i 100
disagree with you and you knew your dad
as this guy that was kind of
you know uh on such a good path in life
and was steering you in the right
direction
and then your older half-sister had
stories that you
almost seemed like a different yeah she
was talking about a different guy well i
remember she said
hey have you talked to dad lately and i
was like
yeah i talk to him all the time he's a
preacher and she goes no no um
larry hendrickson i said yeah yeah he's
a preacher she goes it's impossible
wow he's like no it's not wow
that's crazy um
now during this time also you stayed in
the navy reserves which means you were
doing your one weekend a month or
whatever
and then we go back to the book then an
unexpected opportunity came up
as a naval reservist i could attend
basic underwater demolition school
at naval special warfare training
complex in coronado california buds is a
six month long training class
was part was the first part of navy seal
training so if i ever wanted to become a
seal and member of the
naval special operations community basic
underwater demolition school is where i
had to start my wife sarah
knew that being part of special
operations had always appealed to me now
this opportunity was sitting right in
front of me i had underground
training as a rescue swimmer in the navy
so i had assumed
i had the swimming part down when i was
approved to attend
the six-month buds course visions of
becoming a seal danced in my head
i quickly found out how tough it was
during the first phase of training
a pre-buds training course that lasted
around three weeks
from there i went on to phase one which
consisted of eight weeks of grueling
exercise and conditioning
topped off by hell week typically more
than half the recruits wash out
sheer fatigue and sleep deprivation
cause every candidate to wonder what his
limits are
the non-stop beating that our bodies
took from some of the hardest training
the military has
followed by long stretches of being cold
wet and miserable
with no time to recover took its toll
when my body broke down from a leg
injury and severe pneumonia
i was dropped after three months of
training i could have tried again after
i recovered but i couldn't bring myself
to go through all that [ __ ] again yeah
so what was uh what was that like going
through buds or
attending buds yeah buds was um
i mean i was class 242. uh i i have to
say we're a beat down class
um uh that's that's just my opinion
um you know how they have the classes
where some of them are oh man that's
you guys got secured early from hell
week or whatnot then next class is man
you guys are a beat down class or
whatnot
well we we had a beatdown class and it
was uh it was intense
everything that they talk about it um
yeah
the only thing i can tell any listener
who wants to
contemplate that route is do it because
it's an
experience that you'll never forget they
will make sure you will never forget it
one hundred percent so it was the worst
part you think for you because you know
different guys they dislike different
things
what do you think was the worst part for
you for me the worst part
actually once i got pneumonia
i couldn't breathe and so under and so
when we were doing um drown proofing and
whatnot like that i just
my nose would just start you know
opening up but
i would i would have to say anything
like on on the water
fine under the water i i don't i don't
really like that
i'm not i'm not a very big fan of that
so we when uh well we'll go back to the
book here
for the first time in my life i
experienced a major setback
becoming part of an elite unit was
something i wanted with every inch of my
being but i couldn't make the cut which
prompted a series of questions
why did i fail why wasn't i good enough
how come my body broke down
was i that weak i had no answers and i
came up with every
every poor me excuse in the book you'd
think that for a guy who was raised the
way i was excuses would be the last
thing on my mind
but they were my crutch i slowly but
steadily turned myself into a victim
if only i didn't grow up in a broken
family if only the world and everyone in
it weren't against me
that just wasn't about buds but me not
making it through
brought my buried demons to the surface
so even at this point you know you don't
make it through buds
and you kind of blame all these
you know hey it's all cause i was raised
this way i had these you know my dad my
mom wasn't around
and you kind of make those excuses for
yourself yeah i buried
i buried myself in excuses and it it
became very easy to do that it's very
easy to
to make somebody else the issue instead
of
looking deep inside and and saying hey
man just
you know if if everyone can make it then
it wouldn't be buds
and so um instead of understanding that
you know i i did i took the it was it
was more
it was almost more entitlement than it
was victim is like
well this isn't fair why why didn't i
make the cut and the thing is i could
have rolled back but
i don't know how how far did you make it
um all the way up to the end of the
first phase so
it was yeah it is basically they wanted
me to go
um back to day one of phase one and i
was just like
and you know i just i didn't have it in
me so
but yeah it's you know it's it's one of
those things i look back on
you know and i i do i don't ever regret
anything
but it is one of those things where i'm
like yeah you kind of
you kind of [ __ ] that one up you know so
yeah well uh you know when you say you
had a beatdown class
more than other people it's like i'm
going to tell you the classes
are beat down classes they are beat down
classes you're going to get beat down
you know i was over there
a few months ago with one of my friends
that still works over there
and you know he was like there's there's
whatever there's like a hundred helmets
by the bell
and um and he goes every single one of
those guys
is a stud that wandered he didn't say
everything he's like almost every single
one of those guys is a total stud
that showed up here thinking they were
going to be a seal and they rang that
bell man
and you go i go it's crazy he's he's
like it's it's crazy that's the way it
is
it's a crazy process it's a crazy
machine yep
um so now
you and sarah she's done in the army
you you're now out of the navy and
well here we'll go to the book
everything was perfect so you go to
minnesota and that's because that's
where her family's from yeah so you go
to minnesota
everything was perfect except for one
major problem i could not overcome my
immaturity and my sense of being a
victim
when i refused to take responsibility
for my actions i drank partied and ran
my marriage into the ground i used
whatever excuses i could find
so you're just on a bad path at this
point yeah
it's uh i was on a year's
long bender like i don't think guns n
roses could have held up with me
you get the idea that you should go back
in the military um
you obviously don't want to be in the
navy your wife was in the army so maybe
you're thinking the army's a bad idea so
you go back and check it
check the air force uh
you go here i looked at air force
special operations combat control and
jumped feet first into training i buried
myself in every aspect of the course
until a medical review of my records
showed i had taken depression medication
while in the navy
a lot of people need prescriptions
anti-depressants and depression ran in
my family antidepressant medication
and counseling helped me through a very
dark period of my life
but this detour came back to bite me the
air force decided that i was not
medically qualified for special
operations
and put me in a job where they needed
bodies i was told i would become an
ammunition specialist or ammo troop
so you did they had you already enlisted
when you
did you did you had you already enlisted
when you were gonna try for
for uh cct yes yeah i was already
i mean i was already a couple months
into the training
oh you are actually in the air force
going through cct
training yeah i was at air traffic
control school dang
and then they told you no yeah i mean
the the depression medication it you
know it helped me out through
you know some events in my life or
whatnot the one time i did it
and um and but back in those days and
i'm not making excuses for it but back
in those days
you know the go-to for counselors or
whatnot is here take this
take this take this and so okay i'll
take this
and was that when you were in the navy
so then you were taking a navy
prescribed
thing and they they told you no even
though you're taking something that was
prescribed by the navy
well i had gone out for um civilian
counseling
oh okay yep but i had reported it all
you know like you're supposed to
and um but yeah it was it i mean it's
just back in the days when
it was easier to medicate than to
actually you know kind of
um face your issues and fix them man up
and do the right thing it's just easier
to take some pills and
go to uh go to the spirit world i guess
um but yeah it it came back and got me
so but you know it's um
every you know there's a there's a path
for everybody in life um and
and i firmly believe that you know
the way my life panned out
um i i it was this this is the path that
was gonna happen way before i
was i was ever born i believe i'm
you know god had this path laid out and
you know i was going to take
uh some bumps and bruises along the way
some big ones
but you know now you know to the point
where i'm at right now
so you know i still make my mistakes i'm
a man but
you know i think i'm doing a lot better
at you know
building up people around me instead of
tearing them down like one of the
destructive paths i was on
you know in my life so yeah i know
that's um
that's one of the best things about this
whole story is when you look at
something you took some major
you know like but right there right
those two things
you didn't make it through buds and then
you try for air force combat control and
you don't get that either like those are
two things that people like that's that
could be the last straw
one of those things could be the last
straw i mean and you've already been
through
the hard childhood so any of these
things could be
something that could completely derail
someone's life and and yet you're
sitting here so um
well let's continue let's continue that
telling the story of your path
so you get stationed in idaho you're an
ammo guy you end up going on deployment
to qatar while you're
in qatar you're loading up aircraft that
are going and dropping bombs
oh yeah they were they were winchestered
every night they'd come back
winchester what year was that 2003.
okay um you get divorced
uh now you go to iraq in 2005
you you're in kirkuk and you say this
iraq was the first place out i was
exposed to u.s army special forces the
green berets these bearded shaggy-haired
men
seem to play by their own rules we would
see them
walking by and later that night when the
rest of us were hanging out after dinner
the stories of what we thought we knew
about these guys would spill out
you end up in the you end up in the gym
one time you're lifting and a guy
says you know hey can you spot me and
you look over it's it's this green beret
his name is johnny
days later he introduced me to guys on
his team one guy in particular a dude
named gary
was in the air force before going into
the army this got the wheels in my head
turning
what if i tried to become a green beret
could i do it do i have what it takes
my failure at buds was never far from my
mind when i contemplated my future
one thing was for sure i did not want to
be an old man sitting on my porch
wondering about what might have been
so you go to iraq
as you're when you get back from iraq
you take some leave you go to
dude you you freaking get after you were
talking earlier about like
not leaving not leaving any any uh stone
unturned
you you do some serious traveling you go
to you go to vietnam
you go to ho chi minh city in the mekong
delta and you've got all really cool
stories about all that stuff in here
um you come back from that
you're in idaho and and again
you know you're kind of drinking you're
not feeling like your path you're on the
right path
you go on you go on a trip to europe you
go you end up going to korea
yeah you end up going for was that a
one-year deployment to korea yes
and this is still an air force
deployment you're over there
doing what an ammo specialist does
yeah and playing rugby and playing
wrongly
uh you go while you're over there you go
to
you go to you go to bangkok so you go to
thailand you go to china you go to
cambodia i mean you're
bro you you were getting after this were
you doing military travel are you doing
civilian travel
uh so that was that was for my leave um
so the 30 days of leave or whatnot like
that
but um but yeah so vietnam that was
civilian backpacking around europe that
was civilian everything was
um civilian traveled and it was just
trying to
i don't know i think i don't really know
if i was running from things
more than you know i was just trying to
figure out you know who
who i was because i i had no i had no
direction
um you know i had uh i had my time in
the navy
time in the air force divorced which you
know i
i'm surprised she she made it that long
she's a fighter but
it is what it is so um i ran that one
into the ground
um and i i think i just buried myself
in everything that i could possibly do
just to kind of like keep my mind off of
the fact that
you know i was turning into i was
turning myself into a loser
basically you know and it was becoming
easier and easier to give up
and um and i i still i had that um
i i had buds in the back of my head the
entire time and
um it just i don't know as
i really had a i guess a come to jesus
moment
when i started realizing that giving up
was becoming almost natural
because i was i was the entitled victim
everything was someone else's fault
um in korea you end up with a girl named
jessica which is not a real name but you
end up with a girl you call jessica in
here
and you're just partying and you're
boozing and
you and jessica are i mean this is like
the couple that we all knew
when they were how old are you at this
point uh early 20s
yeah so this is like you know the couple
that's fighting and yelling at each
other and then all of a sudden they're
you know they're going to the club
just like you know i can i could i could
see that
scene yep uh
and of course you guys decide you need
to get married
yep uh which ends up in a pretty quick
divorce
and at this point you you write this in
the book i needed a win
a big win i was never the type to give
up but with two blown marriages a failed
attempt at becoming a navy seal and the
feeling that i hadn't found my calling
in life
i was just settling and letting life run
me ragged i needed to reset my failures
with a major victory
that was when i decided that there would
be no more losing
it was time to start winning again at
the time the air force was over manned
in certain jobs
ammo being one of them the army had a
shortage of
soldiers in certain career fields so the
air force was offering
a direct transfer to the army
one thing my dad had told me years
earlier kept nagging me if you don't try
you'll never know
and if you never know it's because you
didn't try
the answer was clear i wasn't going to
live a life of regrets
even if the high risk of failure was
there
after clearing my head i decided to jump
head first
eyes closed into the unknown
that's you know you want to talk about
there being a plan the fact that the air
force was over manned and the army would
just do a direct transfer
yeah it was it wasn't it was insane
because i was
i was going to the uh to the s1 or the
personnel office whatever
to update some stuff for promotion and
there was this poster on the wall and it
had
uh this guy in two uniforms half of them
was an air air force uniform the other
half was
you know class a's army said blue to
green
and that's and it it all kind of fell
within the same time frame as
you know i i need a victory i need i
need something because right now
um you know my i am i'm 100
um heading down the path of
that i that i probably won't be able to
recover from um if i keep
you know because everything's an excuse
everything's everyone else's fault
um and entitlement and victimization
and i was i was i still wasn't far
enough down the path to where i couldn't
recognize
that i totally became a victim of life's
you know shitty circumstances
and um so i was i was still
able to see like all right you need a
victory you
you need something you got a whole lot
of zeros going you need a one
you know what's weird is i i'm whenever
i talk to vets and people
especially when people get out i'm like
when you get out of the when you get out
of the military you need a new mission
you need to have something else to focus
on but what's weird about this
is you were in the military but the
mission that you had whatever that
mission was it like wasn't bringing you
the satisfaction you didn't feel like it
was
what you should be doing you know you
knew that you had more to offer
and so you're traveling around you're
looking for you're looking for the
mission
yeah and you just couldn't find it and
so then what it's the same thing that
happens when guys get out and they don't
have a mission and all of a sudden they
just go down path of least resistance
and
or bottle the pills or whatever and it
ends up bad
you were still in while you were having
that go on
and luckily they had this opportunity to
go in the army
man so you went to army boot camp and
you talk about that in here
was that was that a little bit of a
gentleman's course do you have you heard
the term gentlemen's course before
um i have yeah okay so it was your boot
camp like a gentleman's course
which in the military gentlemen's
courses is basically
there it's basically you're there to
actually learn it's not like this
beat down thing um you're gonna actually
learn stuff you get treated like a human
you're not getting treated like a
like a you know new guy piece of [ __ ]
whatever you're getting treated well
and you're there to learn that's a
gentleman's course
uh for instance i went to officer
candidate school
with all the other people coming out of
college that go to officer candid school
that's not a gentleman's course like you
go and you get all the
full benefit of people yelled and
screaming at you but
for warrant officers or or limited duty
officers in the navy they go to a
gentleman's course where
hey here's how you wear the uniform and
here's here's what here's how you write
these reports it's like a nice
transition yeah sounds like yours was
somewhere in between
you kind of had to go to boot camp a
little bit but
they were being cool to you so yeah
infantry basic was
that there was two things that happened
there um number one so i had
i had done the um the prior service
uh course that they had for us in new
mexico
which was supposed it was supposed to
suffice as
you know that was the phase one of
infantry basic then you go to
um ait when you say infantry basic
is that boot camp straight up boot camp
so you went to his class in new mexico
how long was that
course um that was a month and then
okay a normal army boot camp is what 12
weeks
yeah i think so they gave you a little
shortened course were they cool to you
or were they yelling and screaming
so uh new mexico they can't really yell
and scream a bunch of you know they're
a bunch of guard guys that were kind of
which no offense i mean
definitely but um they um they were just
there to check the boxes on
us so they're there to actually
transition you okay this is the way it
works in the army here's how you wear
your uniform in the army these are the
roles responsibilities so it was it was
a gentleman's course it was cool
that was and then i get to benning for
infantry and um
apparently i didn't get the memo that i
was supposed to wait for
ait so i started basic
with everyone else and so the drill
instructor
he uh he came up to me hey man not like
you're not supposed to be here and i
basically told him like hey
i need this you know i need something to
bury completely just
focus everything i got on it bury
all of my efforts into into into a cause
and and i loved it like i loved it and
um he's like hey
you know we're you're gonna have to play
the game then i was like i'll play the
game i got
i got nothing but time so it was awesome
i i loved it and so i would think for a
private going through
when i went through they probably would
say it was not a gentleman's course but
for me
um going through basic you know our
infantry basic and whatnot like that
it was it was exactly what i needed
at that point in time every day was
awesome and it just kept my mind off of
everything that i just went through
everything so
but it still didn't fix it it just kept
my mind off it
uh you end up so you go through that
infantry basic you go through
ait you go to airborne then
you start the 18x which is when you're
going into special forces and you're not
exactly sure which
uh specialty you're gonna get they call
it 18x
and you go to this 18x prep course
and you say this uh
18x prep course was extremely hard and
pushed me to my limits i'm talking
non-stop physical training 12 hours per
day getting beat down
the intent of the prep program was not
only to get a soldier ready
mentally and physically for selection
but also to weed out the week
so how long is that prep course it um
it depends but our um 18 x-ray um
the prep course for selection i think
ours was a month
so four weeks and then from prep course
you go to
special forces selection yes so prep
course is literally just to get you
ready
like yes hard pts and they're trying to
get you
in good physical shape to be ready for
for special forces selection yes or
to help you understand that this isn't
really what you want and so they don't
blow a bunch of money training you they
can just
send you over to the 82nd really quick
and move on with life
got it so now you get to special forces
selection i'm gonna go to the book
this was do or die time an 18 day gut
check to pull out all the stops there
was no way
i would accept failure because i didn't
think i could handle another [ __ ] up in
my life
this was most likely my only chance and
i was going to make it happen
everything that i've been through all
the hard work i'd put in everything led
up to this point selection
as soon as we stepped off the buses at
camp mccall it was game on we started
with the usual army pt test a readiness
assessment
also known as the army physical fitness
test to my surprise some soldiers
showed up for a shot to be the best
failed the first pt test
and were gone on day zero fast forward a
little bit time was flying by for me and
i was killing it regardless of whether
it was a 10 mile
run along sandy backwoods roads a 10k
rucksack march with 60 pounds on my back
a 12 mile land navigation course
rifle pt log pt with telephone poles or
the dreaded team week events that broke
the will of most of the trainees
i was speeding through as excruciating
as everything was i was amazed at how
well i was doing
the 18x prep course lived up to his name
so you're
kind of getting after it doing good yeah
we were constantly on the move 18 to 20
hours a day whether it was a ball buster
pt session or hustling from one event to
the other
shot i came in snatches and meals were
always on the go
not getting enough food for me was not
getting enough food
for the number of calories i was burning
took its toll after the first week but i
didn't care
while the lack of calories depleted my
energy and strength that combined with
my lack of sleep
was all part of the men mentally and br
and physically breaking down a trainee
so you're not eating very much which is
one thing that i always
was happy that i ended up in the navy
and going to buds instead of
any of the army courses where you don't
get to eat man yeah they aren't the
the army seems to uh they they really
like the whole
you don't need to eat thing yeah yeah
the navy focuses on uh you don't need to
sleep
yeah and and also you don't need to be
warm which look
ranger school and freaking sf school you
know it's not like you're warm or cuddly
there either
no no the uh just beat downs we just
we're not under the water
and that was good
uh as the days turned into weeks our
bodies were breaking down so i pressed
on as we neared the end
the final major obstacle in my way was a
long ruck march we weren't supposed to
know the distance of the final trek but
every selection class got the scoop from
guys are gone before we'd be going 25 to
30 miles
turned out you guys went more than 25 to
again i'm jumping you give some really
cool information and that's why people
should get the book
um fast forward a little bit after
hitting the finish line we gathered in a
large conference hall to hear who got
selected and who didn't i could barely
put one foot in front of the other but
at least i walked in
under my own power those left standing
after the dust cleared
looked like they had spent years as pows
most of the guys hobbled and limped
their way into the conference hall
beaten down
and on edge as i took my seat
my tired head was filled with questions
will all this physical and mental effort
be for nothing
did i give it the best i could do i have
what they are looking for
after a wait that seemed like days the
selection cadre
entered the hall to call off the roster
numbers of the guys selected
i was roster number 049 out of 185
as he went down the list he reached
those in the 40s
i held my breath and closed my eyes
roster number zero four
nine selected
i melted into my chair as the relief
spread over my body out of 185
only 50 or so men were selected a little
more than one out of every four
i was one of them but i wasn't there yet
i still had more hurdles in front of me
out of the 50 of us who would advance to
the qualification course less than half
would become green berets
those concerns didn't matter to me at
that point however for now i savored my
accomplishment i was on my way
so you you do this freaking all this
training of selection how long selection
18 days
yeah it it it varies there's some three
week selections and whatnot but yeah i
had an 18 day selection
and then even if you pass everything
you can still just not get selected yes
there was
a lot of those guys who they said hey
thank you for coming out
um you're just not what we're looking
for good luck
damn so you're sitting in there with
your freaking fingers crossed
yeah yeah dang yeah do you have any idea
what they're like what is the kind of
thing where they're saying that this
guy's not not for us
so the because i would be pissed yeah
some of the lessons that i've learned
and uh some of the things that
you know i can i think make a good
operator regardless of what special
operations
unit you're with is a guy who's always
looking for work
you're never stagnant look for work a
guy who's always willing to carry the
heaviest [ __ ]
um look for work carry heavy stuff
and then the guy who he just
regardless of how bad it hurts
smile because you're making memories
that you're
you're just you're not you can never
recreate it ever so
look for work carry heavy stuff and
smile yeah that's that's
very good advice uh we used to actually
we used to tell guys you know especially
when i was
running training that was one of the
things we tell guys is look for work
even
in a tactical sense like hey you're
sitting there with your
weapon pointed down the ground bro look
for work go find something to cover go
find some
hold security somewhere look for work
make something happen
and that's right in there i mean that's
almost the same thing as carry heavy
[ __ ]
yeah yeah don't be the guy that's trying
to shirk that
yep if uh if the 240 is on the ground
and everyone's moving to a different
weapon system grab the
because i can promise you one thing it
will not be the heaviest thing you'll
carry in combat
training can't touch a combat load
yeah no doubt uh so from there
you go to the q course and i guess in
route to q course or part of the q
course
the q course is like a whole bunch of
things racked up together right is that
right
so you do see your school you do crc
school
you you go to language school
which you did spanish yes and
and well this was kind of funny um
you're like before selection i was given
a language aptitude test
my score determined the difficulty of
the language i would learn well let's
just say that ryan hendrickson's test
results were modest at best
and i would not be learning arabic or
mandarin chinese oh no
no no so and you also said this you
would joke with your friends while
you're taking spanish i can barely speak
american let alone mexican yeah
yeah our teacher did not like that uh
so then you go to robin sage and robin
sage is this famous
green beret exercise that you do at the
end of the q course over a period of
three weeks we would plan in full train
advise and assist a resistance movement
that on some level back the united
states and was seeking to defeat the
occupying
repressive forces in pineland which is a
made-up place in western north carolina
this would be by far the most realistic
military exercise to prepare men for
what we would actually encounter
while deployed when times were hard and
i needed to pull strength from somewhere
anywhere
i would see someone in the course who i
had fought who i thought had no business
being there
someone who was riding the coattails of
others performing only when the
spotlight was on him
i would pick these guys out and think
i'm not going
anywhere if this guy is still here i'm
better than this
[ __ ] bag and i will outlast him no
matter what
then that guy would fail or quit and i
would target someone else
i knew that i was better than i would
use their weaknesses to make me stronger
in a crazy way i fed off their failures
be bad good or indifferent this was the
mindset i used to keep pushing myself
just i i mean for me when people were
quitting
i would i was always like damn what a
loser
i guess i had a little bit of that and
there was a couple people that surprised
me when they quit
there was one guy in my bud's class that
was like uh
he had gone to buds before he was an e5
he was probably like 25 or 26 years old
which seemed pretty freaking old to me
and like mature
because i was still like what not you
know
and i'm thinking oh he's got he's got
this stuff off and he would like give me
advice like hey you need to when the
instructors do this you know and
you need to keep this mind i was like
okay you know it sounds good and then
it's
freaking first night of hell week he
quits
and i was like what freaking what's your
problem
but but the same thing i was kind of
like all right well i'm definitely not
quitting this freaking loser
uh so then for 84 weeks that's 20 months
from start to finish my tired and broken
body performed at levels i didn't think
were possible i pushed myself to my
limits
and through to the end life had dealt me
some major blows
and no one knew better than me that i
dug a hole for myself that was damn near
impossible to get out of
despite how much i had [ __ ] things up
i had pulled myself
out of the pit started something and
seen it through it to the end leaving
nothing behind
i'd given this everything and i had
succeeded now as a green beret
ready to write the next chapter of my
life damn
that's already like one full book right
there
just needed one victory yeah that's it
damn um and i like what you said earlier
you know you were talking about your dad
being like able to turn himself around
and that's the same
you know it's the same story for you too
you know you're going from a horrible
spot
where you've racked up some some
failures and then you just
get it together get focused and you win
you start winning
uh fast forward a little bit okay here's
the sergeant major talking you're
checking in
okay you're the new 18 charlie i've been
waiting for
i'm assigning you to oda7215
i knew the seven stood for seventh
special forces
the two for second battalion the one for
alpha company and the five for fifth
team in the company
i knew my job as an 18 charlie well talk
about what an 18 charlie is
so 18 charlie is a demolition expert on
an oda
and we you know we have the different
mos's like the
18 bravo weapon weapons expert 18 echo
comms um charlie uh demolitions
and also construction but stateside you
are
a uh a special forces supply guy it's
really sorry
is it is it technically engineering
right yep yep so that's the
that's where the charlie is yep and then
you know the fox intel
and you know team sergeant zulu and
whatnot like that and delta
medical so um
so you say this and this is a weird
thing because you don't think when you
think engineers you think
building and and constructing and
this happens in the marine corps too
engineers becomes the people that handle
ieds
so i knew my job as an 18 charlie wasn't
for the faint of heart while patrolling
in enemy held areas of afghanistan i
would find myself
up front the tip of the spear one might
say
with three to five afghan counterparts
who specialized in counter ied
operations and we're very good at
finding them we would be exposed to
taliban snipers or any run-of-the-mill
dumbass
wanting to take a shot at us the worst
part of being the man up front
was that i would be the first soldier to
encounter the ieds i'd rather be in a
firefight with the taliban any day of
the week then deal
with ieds which were a nasty but very
effective way to fight a war
one of the senior one of the more senior
guys in the back corner spoke up
you got a lot to learn in a little bit
of time sit down and listen but most of
all keep your mouth shut keep your eyes
open
this will be a fire hose and you you get
man you do a good job in the book of
of talking about the team and checking
into the team and you're a new guy and
you go through all that stuff
um but we're gonna skip through that and
people need to buy the book to get that
information
i'm going straight to afghanistan you're
heading toward
an outpost the outpost is called the
alamo which is always a good sign
yeah not sure what happened there but i
don't think it ended up very well
uh so here you are oh [ __ ]
not only was i my first mission as a
green beret but i was walking into a
live combat situation because you guys
had heard gunfire
this wasn't a video game real 762
caliber bullets would be flying
this caliber of bullet would easily rip
a hole the size of a silver dollar
through a man's torso and tara's
internal organs to shreds we wore body
armor that gave some protection to our
chest and upper backs but when a bullet
penetrated the chest cavity
nine times out of ten you were dead i
was driving the lead vehicle when our
convoy arrived at the last stopping
point
around a thousand meters from the alamo
a call came over to vehicle radio
communications all vehicles stop
during our pre-mission brief that
morning i remember being told
that we would have to make a mad dash
over a one kilometer
over one kilometer of open ground to
reach the safety of the alamo so we
needed to be prepared for that
the alamo was surrounded by a u-shaped
ridge line a finger-like natural rock
structure that ran
toward the helmand river then the call
came over the radio
all vehicles move i hit the gas on my rg
mine resistant vehicle and started
covering ground within seconds the
taliban machine gun crew started sending
rounds our way
i heard pings from the bullets hitting
our truck thank god the rg-33 was
armored
sprays of dirt and dust from incoming
bullets engulfed our vehicle my senses
shot up to overdrive
and adrenaline pumped through my veins
even though i was scared i had never
felt so alive as i concentrated on
keeping the heavy vehicle moving forward
then crack we'd been hit the front
windshield split in a hundred different
directions like a spider's web
crack crack two more rounds hit my
windshield
i didn't know how many more rounds this
windshield could take drive my captain
yelled from the
front passenger seat we got to get the
[ __ ] off this open ground
i jam the gas pedal to the floorboard
and push the rg-33 to its limits
limits and rg 33 weighs around 38 000
pounds so maneuvering such a large
bullet magnet
over a thousand meters of of uneven
rough terrain was no easy task
i managed to rumble to safety through
the alamo single entrance gate and into
a large courtyard
the other two vehicles arrived safely as
well almost as soon as my rg33 stopped
in the courtyard
i jumped out and ran to the nearest
elevated position in the compound i
toggled the selector switch on my m4
carbine
from safe to fire and started sending
rounds downrange toward the enemy
for the next few hours we exchanged
sporadic gunfire but i have to admit
that it was hard to think clearly
adrenaline had really taken over my body
at that point training kicked in and i
reacted with muscle memory
that had been honed through hundreds of
hours spent training for combat
when my first battle experience was over
i couldn't get my hands to quit shaking
my nerves were tingling as well
but i felt good the question of how i
would react when bullets were flying had
been answered
that evening some of the guys looked at
the damage on my vehicle we could see
where the rounds hit
even though bullets hadn't made holes
but the indentations were everywhere
damn one more round hitting your
windshield and it was gone one of my
teammates said
you'd have been [ __ ] up you got that
right i said
looks like you got your cib bro joked
another buddy which is the combat
infantryman's jet badge
and they're telling you yeah you just
got it so there's your welcome to combat
yeah that was uh day three
day three and um that that happened and
it was uh it was awesome it was awesome
i mean it's hard to explain it
but it was so awesome that it you know
it's
it's addicting you know combats it's a
rush
so that's and i got that day three yeah
yeah that's a that's a good welcome
there it's it's
uh i remember the first time i went into
it was an rg33 if it was one
i think it was an rg33 what was that
there was one other vehicle
i forget the name of it so they had um
so the mat the mac vs um the rg31s
they also have the um matvs or the max
pro
i think it was a 33 um
but i remember driving through ramadis i
i'd probably been in ramadi for like a
month at this point and
all the all my transits would either in
a bradley which you can't see anything
or in a humvee which you can barely see
and you're all freaking having to scan
so the first time i rolled down route
michigan in an rg33 sitting at like 15
feet with the white lights on and the
big giant
bulletproof windows it's like the
coolest thing ever you're like
i'm good and you can look around and you
can like really pay attention
so that's that's it that's a good
feeling as opposed to humvee where
you're just waiting to suck start an ied
and
die uh
yeah so now you guys are doing rotations
out at this place the alamo it's like a
forward operating base
yeah it was a it was a cop that's
basically we took over a compound
um old chicken
farm goat cow whatever compound and
turned it into
basically where we were going to conduct
operations
engage in taliban forces along the
helmand river
you say i learned quickly that 90 of a
deployment was sheer boredom followed by
of heart racing terror and excitement
each rush of combat left me craving more
there was something about the kill or be
killed aspect of fighting that gave me a
high a high that was dangerously
addicting
during my first three months in
afghanistan my detachment saw combat got
caught in several
intense fire fights but we didn't take
any casualties
the rest of the men of alpha company
second battalion however
2010 was proving to be one hell of a
deadly deployment two men on a different
detachment were killed in action
including one of our air force
counterparts and more than a dozen were
wounded
normally a deployment to afghanistan
resulted in four or five wounded guys
and maybe one fallen soldier
but our company more than doubled or
tripled that amount
one afternoon our team leader approached
me to tell me that a friend of mine
named jason had been killed in action
that day in a different part of
afghanistan
jason died in a v jason died when his
vehicle hit an id he said
damn man this [ __ ] sucks are you gonna
be okay
i absorbed the emotional blow yeah i'm
good i said even though my chest was
closing in
i hadn't known jason that long but we
had gone through a large portion of
special forces training together back at
fort bragg
it's through training that you really
get to know someone i knew i could
always count on jason for help
there were times i felt like i was a
fish out of water coming over from the
air force the army but jason took the
time to help me whenever i got hung up
on whatever part of training i was stuck
with
jason was someone i looked up to i
admired how everything was easy for him
he was smart in great shape a super dad
to his kids an amazing husband to his
wife
but just two months into his first
deployment as a green beret
he was dead
in the past i had heard about guys from
a different battalion or unit dying in
iraq or afghanistan
but this was the first time i knew
someone personally death in combat was
not just something i saw on the news now
it was personal jason was my friend
and this was the ugly reality of war
i tried my best not to think about
jason's death too much
which was difficult i knew full well
that afghanistan
was not the place to mourn the death of
friends there would be plenty of time
back in the states to think about that
and try to come to terms with it
i still had a job to do to make sure no
one on my team stepped on an ied
and a promise to fulfill to myself i
would do whatever it took to make sure
my teammates returned with to their
families in one piece
in 2010 though afghanistan was not
getting safer
and the real fighting had yet to begin
how long had you guys been on deployment
for at that point
um so when jason was killed uh
i think i was we both got in the country
at the same time and um so that would be
two months
and how long are your how long were your
deployments at this point
um they ran they varied um but most of
them were
nine months at that at that point so
so you're only two months into a
nine-month deployment you've already
your your your battalion's lost a bunch
of guys your company's had guys wounded
and killed now your friend gets killed
going back to the book when summer was
coming to a close my team along with
other odas from our company was tasked
with entering
chutu valley i say that right yep from
different locations and clearing out the
taliban to a central point which would
send the bastards running for the
mountains working against us however
was the fact that this was not a covert
mission everyone up and down the valley
knew we were coming
which gave the taliban ample time to
place ieds
and prepare for us
so you go you talk through some of the
planning
and finally you guys go to execute this
mission the date was september 10th
2010. each of us was carrying a
different equipment
carrying different equipment for the
mission besides my body armor and m4
rifle
i was toting a 60-pound assault pack on
my back filled with ammunition
demolition material
food water extra batteries and whatever
else i would need for three days my
average fighting weight was 200 pounds
but with body armor weapons ammo and my
assault pack i probably tipped the
scales at 280.
280s being generous yeah
you say during our our final pre-mesh
and checks
i had time to let my mind wander
what will be out there waiting for us do
they know we're coming how hard will it
be to find ieds how
i react when the bullets start flying
all these questions
plagued my mind as i was watching the
river flow
in the light of the moon until it
disappeared into the darkness this
seemed like a good moment to take out a
small pad of paper
from my assault pack and write a quick
note from my family in case the worst
happened
dad wendy paula chris and robbie i hope
i made you proud
if you're reading this note i did not
make it
death doesn't really scare me because
i'm doing what i believe is right and
just
i guess that's really all you can ask
from a man
death comes to everyone at some point in
life so there's no use fighting it
when it's your time it's your time and
there's nothing you can do about it
i believed i live as good a life as
possible and i'm asking you not to stay
sad very long
very soon you will be joining me in
heaven and we will again be together
i'll keep the beer cold for you all i
love you
ryan
i don't know why i chose to write this
note maybe it was the fact that i was a
new guy and had no clue what would
happen on my first patrol
that far from the alamo maybe i had seen
too many war movies and figured this was
a good idea
maybe deep down i really believed that
this mission was destined to have a
terrible outcome
whatever the reason i chose to write
down exactly what i felt at that moment
because i wanted my family to hear from
me
one last time if the worst happened i
folded the note
placed it in a ziploc bag so it wouldn't
get damaged if it got wet
and stuck it to my right arm stuck it in
my right arm
front uniform pocket where god willing
someone would find it and pass the
letter along to my family
uh did did you
have the uh proverbial bad feeling about
this op
so you know looking back now and i
remember
you know sitting there and i and i got
to thinking
um
everyone up and down the valley knew we
were coming and the first set of
um villages were deserted and so
you know as as you well super bad sign
um i don't i to this day i don't know
why i decided to write that note
um again it could just be too many war
movies i
i have no idea but did you save it i do
i got it at home
but uh but yeah it just seems didn't you
think you were jinxing yourself
so i do worry about that a little bit
but because i never wrote i would get
that
like no i'm not writing that nothing's
gonna happen i'm good
i just had this i don't know i just had
this weird feeling plus
you know being up in the front it's
it's kind of like oh man and i
i don't know i just think i just think
you know getting caught up in all the
emotion of everything and um
and you're amped up you're ready to go
you're ready for the green light
and everything like that and it's like
all right let me let me bust this out
man because i just really don't know
so yeah it was very um
uncertain what we were walking into yeah
the
the freaking ieds are crazy you know
you're going into an ied
thick area you know you're the first guy
and even if you're not getting an ied
you're the person that's walking into an
ambush
oh yeah you're gonna get shot in the
face
good times so finally you get the call
uh from ben let's move out guys
we slowly charged our way toward the
village of
sartutu in the distance sartutu is made
up
of several mud hut compounds and my
group was tasked with clearing one of
the sections
keeping strict noise and light
discipline we scanned the hillsides and
the riverbank for any movement
i kept my thumb on my weapon safety
selector ready to switch it to engage
to kill the enemy taking fire from the
taliban was a risk we all knew was
possible
but the more likely scenario was
experiencing a catastrophic
ied explosion resulting in the loss of
limbs and broken bodies
all the team members were fully aware
that one wrong step could change their
lives forever
my job was to make sure that did not
happen these insidious bombs could be
hidden
anywhere buried in the ground hung in
trees stashed in cooking pots
inside the carcasses of dead animals
within car trunks or under clothing
with the infamous strap-on suicide vests
while they might have been built with
fertilizer and discarded spare parts and
looked like a junior high school shop
class project
i never underestimated the lethality of
these homemade bombs
all i took was a handful all it took was
a handful of high explosives
a few inches of copper wire and a
battery detonation could be triggered by
compression the weight of a soldier or
vehicle passing over the explosive
charge
remote control with cell phones or an
electrical circuit
from a distance the taliban were limited
only by their imagination
which was limitless when it came to
killing americans
moving up we intercepted a radio
transmission from the taliban indicating
that they knew we were on the move
and could see us at first the news made
my heart race
my palms got sweaty as my arms as my
eyes darted around
looking for anything slightly abnormal i
felt i was starting to see things that
really weren't there
were my eyes playing tricks on me or my
ears it seemed like i was
hearing all sorts of things when we
stopped to get our bearings the guys
called this hyperventilates
hypervigilance and told me that when
danger was imminent
your senses rose up several notches to
high alert status
fueling the hypersensitivity was an
overwhelming desire to stay alive
the village was deserted when we entered
one thing every
sf guy knew was that when you entered a
village and it's deserted
you better figure that you're in for a
big fight or a village full of ieds
in our minds ieds were a coward's way of
fighting but no one could deny
that they were extremely effective we
had to clear each compound or home so we
advanced slowly and deliberately looking
for anything suspicious
or out of the ordinary that could
conceal an ied we were professional
soldiers
details matter a slight discoloration of
the dirt
a suspicious pile of rocks an abandoned
water pail
a tree that had been tagged with a
marker a disturbance in a mud wall
or a lone person walking quickly
directly toward us anything
mattered
but we didn't see any people or anything
questionable even though i assumed every
doorway and window
had a pair of eyes looking at me and my
buddies after we hit
our first planned stopping point the
team broke up into smaller elements to
cover a bigger area
in and around the village including a
world war one like trench
that ran adjacent to the helmand river
one of the taliban's favorite positions
to fight us from
each element was made up of two or three
green berets and a handful of afghan
fighters assisting us
in clearing the village my element
consisted of myself
our team sergeant lance and six afghans
one of whom was nick our interpreter
nick wasn't the man's real name but
everybody who supported our team was
giving
given an easy to remember nickname for
the ease of communication
our job alongside the afghans was to
clear the first set of compounds
running parallel to the river once the
compounds were clear we would move on to
the next set
as i approached within 15 meters of the
first compound i watched for everything
and anything
from movement in the compounds to
variations in the terrain where i was
stepping
i stopped and turned around to check on
lance who was behind me with several
afghans he gave me a nod
meaning i could keep moving with the
afghans and check out the first compound
i motioned to nick to come closer tell
your guys to move up and clear the
compound i said keep your [ __ ] eyes
open
we both knew what that meant sweep the
car your courtyard
while watching every nook and cranny for
a rifle barrel
waiting to open fire nick turned and
relayed my direction to the handful of
afghan soldiers
instead of moving they stood there like
statues
as precious seconds passed by it became
clear to me
that they were not going to move what
the [ __ ] i thought
do they not understand what i need them
to do are they too scared to go
i whispered to nick what's the problem
it's too dangerous nick replied
no [ __ ] of course this was dangerous
this was what war was all about
i knew they were scared i was too i
figured they wanted the americans to go
first because they felt we had better
weapons and knew we were better fighters
i kept my cool and refrained from losing
my temper but i was pissed
this is your damn country so fight for
it i turned around to have a word with
lance
when out of the corner of my eye i saw
nick moving toward the front of the
compound about 15 meters from me
where a wooden door into our first mud
hut was slightly ajar
what's he doing why is he walking into
an uncleared part of the compound
without afghan soldiers leading the way
he was my damn interpreter not a fighter
i knew better than to yell
out to stop him since that could have
invited a firefight
even though the taliban were on the move
tactically it was best to assume
the enemy did not know where we were and
to remain relatively undetected for as
long as possible in case taliban
fighters
were inside the compound and waiting to
spring a nasty surprise
lance grabbed me by the arm get nick
away from that door
this wasn't the place or time for an
afghan rambo
even though 15 meters wasn't a lot of
ground to cover each step was a gamble
in taliban controlled area i carefully
but quickly moved up to nick and grabbed
his arm
nick don't move bro we need to move back
to lance's position and regroup
this is uncleared ground nick looked at
me
we're going to back away slowly i
continued i want you to place
your feet over my boot prints and slowly
move with me
back to lance if you stay in my steps
you'll be okay
nick did not want to retreat we can
still get our guys inside the compound
he said
no the time is not right i reiterated we
need to get reorganized
the firmness in my voice told nick that
i meant business
he started to move back from the
compound and retreated slowly as well
and i retreated slowly as well
making sure i had my m4 ready to rock in
case someone in the compound
moved around the corner and opened fire
on us
my eyes were sweeping the compound as
well as looking where i placed my feet
i took one slow step after another
when
a deafening explosion pounded my
eardrums at this
at the same instant a hot searing
brighter than midday flash of light
enveloped me
the blast shattered the silence across
the valley sending birds into the sky as
they flapped their wings and screeched
the concussive explosion knocked me to
the ground like a blind side hit from a
line black
linebacker in an instant i landed on my
back just outside the compound entrance
the foul ammonia smelling air clogged my
lungs
and choked my breathing i instinctively
rubbed the grip from my eyes and waited
for the dust to settle
trying as hard as i could to breathe but
i could only manage
the barest of breaths i fought for air
as i fought for air a yellow brown cloud
swirled around me i couldn't see my
hands in front of my face because of all
the dust
in the air i shook my head and yawned a
couple times trying to squelch the high
pitch ringing in my ears but that didn't
work
then i opened my mouth to scream for
nick wanting to make sure he was okay
but nothing came out
the thickness of the dust with the
overwhelming smell of ammonia saturated
the air
and made it impossible to yell or to
take a full
gulp of air
i'm not sure what just happened but if i
don't get fresh air i will suffocate
in those first few disorienting moments
i didn't feel any pain so i had to be
okay i tried to stand but then i fell
back over in a heap
damn i tried again but i couldn't stand
up what the [ __ ] what's happening to me
i was having trouble thinking clearly
then in a moment then a moment or two
later i suddenly realized what had
happened
i had stepped on an ied
damn um
when you were going through that
compound to grab nick
there was still this was still there had
been no compromise yet
like it was just silence yeah there was
no compromise
it was that the quietest i think
i'll ever remember any environment being
was
that's the scene just incredibly
creepy quiet and you're trying to
step in the boot prints that you made
when you
get when you went to get nick so you're
walking backwards
so kind of sort of um you know all of us
know that you never
turn your back or your side to the
unknown and so
past the breach point is the unknown so
we have the breach or the
doorway or whatever you want to call it
and so
what it what had happened was i was
trying to move back
but then you know how when you're the
very last man in a patrol you're
constantly doing the
whoop sorry you're constantly doing the
back look well that's
kind of what i was doing making sure
that my m4 was
ready to start putting rounds into the
compound um
and yeah so and it's and it's still
like the sun wasn't up yet the the sky
was getting light
but the sun wasn't quite up yet so you
know it was
yeah it's just the perfect perfect storm
it's like that time where you're not
sure if you're better off with nods or
off nods oh yeah like that moment of the
morning yep
yep within about 10 minutes you're
taking your nods off and storing them
yeah it was that
that perfect moment of zero viz
back to the book i suddenly became aware
of the pain it was slowly creeping in
like a snake
squeezing his victim to death i reached
down from my left leg and wiggled it leg
was still there
bloody but still there when i tried to
move my right leg however the pain was
unbearable
waving the sand and dust away with my
hands to get a better view i could see
my right combat boot was bent at a weird
90 degree angle
it was like my combat boot made a t at
the end of my leg
it didn't seem possible that my leather
boot could be twisted like that so i
grabbed my right leg
behind my right knee and lifted to get a
better look
as i raised my right leg up a tad my
right
foot flopped off to the side of my leg
oh [ __ ] the only thing connecting my
foot to my leg was stringy
bloody red muscle tissue and ragged skin
what was more disturbing was seeing the
stark white bones poking out of my leg
i was amazed at how glistening white
they were in contrast with my bloody leg
oh god this was bad i'm hit i'm hit i'm
hit
so
what's crazy about these situations is
when
there's an in your any these ied
environments
no one can move like you can't just go
oh my buddy is hurt
i'm gonna go help him that's the wrong
move you have to
you have to actually freeze and not move
yep where there's one there's five yeah
and and you find out later that this was
a little bit of a well not a full low
order detonation detonation
but there was probably 20 pounds and
only seven or only only like a third of
the the ied went off
yep otherwise you wouldn't be here right
now no there would be
they they could have put what was left
of me in a plastic bag if the whole
thing would have went off
uh these guys they do and again you know
you do a great job describing the stuff
in the book
um i mean there's one part where you say
i hear the team sergeant lanciell don't
move ryan
and you yell back where the [ __ ] do you
think i'm going
because you're sitting there wounded
yeah um
yeah second stretched by like hours i'd
never been in so much pain or felt so
alone it was like i was the only person
in that village i lay on my side in the
dirt waiting for the bright light
everyone says you see before you die
lance was the closest american to me
but i knew he couldn't rush to me
because i had walked into an ied filled
area
chances were that he would be next and
then what
and in that moment it was impossible it
was impossible to think clearly
this is it i'm going to die in this
[ __ ] village in afghanistan
as i lay there for what seemed like
hours i prayed harder than i had in
years this was serious i felt like i was
on the cusp of eternity
i'd always heard there were no atheists
in foxholes and i guess they were right
i was a christian who had accepted jesus
christ into my heart years ago
but i had strayed from the path of
righteousness since then to say the
least
nonetheless i made peace with god and
figured he understood
the mistakes i had made in my life came
back to me but so did the things i had
done right i asked for forgiveness for
my sins
and for the people i had hurt in the
state of mind i was in i felt this could
be my last chance to make things right
suddenly i felt a calm calm over me that
i couldn't explain
explain the pain lessened as i felt like
i was fading into a deep sleep
i thought of some of the good times i
had had in my life fourth of july
barbecued was
loved ones watching the fireworks
without a care in the world traveling
around the world and all the amazing
experience that brought me
but most of all i was thinking about my
family and how much at that moment i
missed them
i hoped i had made my family proud but i
also felt a strong sense of nagging
guilt for letting my team down
no green beret wants that to happen but
it did i fought back tears because i
felt like i had failed my team
five minutes or so after stepping on the
ied i knew i was hanging on for dear
life
i could feel my life myself slipping
away i'd heard so many
say that your life flashes before your
eyes just before you go but that wasn't
happening i didn't know if that was a
good thing or a bad thing
stay awake lance yell don't pass out
ryan we're moving
and you uh i skipped over this part but
you had been trying to get a tourniquet
on yourself and you like couldn't get it
done
no i yeah i couldn't get it done because
i um
so i i pulled one of the rookie mistakes
where usually on your kit you rubber
band the tourniquet on
correct well as you know what if that's
security
i'm gonna double secure it i'm to use
zip ties oh
yeah so oops oops
uh fast forward a little bit i felt a
slap
sharp i felt a sharp slap across my face
and another and another each one harder
than the last
what the [ __ ] i opened my eyes and i
found myself lying still in the dirt of
the
this pissant village my teammate george
screamed stay awake ryan keep your eyes
open
so he's just slapping you trying to so
is this all just blood loss um
blood loss but i think more of it was
shock and i don't i don't really
understand how shock works
but i i know it could kill you and so
um there was some blood loss there but
it was
you know everything that had built up to
you know
george um slapping the crap out of me
um that was i i think i dealt with a lot
of shock
what was going on because i mean it's
you know stepped on an ied
yeah uh and then dude they give you some
morphine and you get hive so it turns
out you're allergic to morphine
yeah it's not a good time to find out
uh eventually and again you got to read
the book but eventually kyle
who must be a hoss lifts kyle couldn't
move fast enough because
he lifts you up he's buddy carrying you
kyle couldn't move fast enough because
it was body armor and gear along with
200 pound man over his shoulder
lz was a long ways away more than 500
meters
the team took turns carrying me while
keeping security high the taliban knew i
was hit because our afghan interpreter
monitoring their radio traffic could
hear them celebrating
and laughing about hitting me
so they get you to the lz um they get
you extracted
and then the next thing you know you're
showing up in the
in uh taren cot in the
in the hospital you get pissed because
they're going to cut off your shirt
which is one of your
what's your freaking lucky shirt my
lucky oregon ducks football shirt yeah
uh but they end up cutting it off um
and again you know you do you give do a
great job talking about the medical team
and
the doctors and nurses and the staff
that freaking
takes care of you and and keeps you
alive
get you stabilized and then from there
you go to kaf um
more surgeries they're trying to clean
you know trying to clean it out
and and then it's over to germany
you end up in ramstein um
and then at long stool i mean then again
i'm just jumping through a bunch of
stuff that you got to read the book
because
you know it's it's it's all it's all
part of the story what you're going
through
i mean
yeah yeah i'll pull one little quote you
say so i'm out on patrol trying to find
ieds my damn metal detector wasn't
working so i closed my eyes and stomped
around to clear the route boom found one
mission success
um you say here i've been to germany
many times during my military career but
this time it felt different because i
was fresh off the battlefields of
afghanistan
i finally felt safe when the aircraft
landed no longer a dangerous part of the
world i could finally relax or so i
thought
what i didn't know is that now i'd have
plenty of time to actually think about
everything that had happened to me
i would also have time to cry over my
friends who didn't make it home alive
the ones placed into coffins for the
one-way flight to dover air force base
in delaware
a grim trip that no one wants to take i
don't have time to think about the
families torn apart because of war
either because they lost a loved one or
their soldier was coming home with a
mangled body
never to be the same again that was my
situation as well
i knew i was never going to be the same
again
all right um
again jumping ahead here where you end
up at brook army medical center
bma bamc fort sam houston texas
fast forward after i woke up from my
15th surgery
an unexpected visitor stepped in my room
where i was resting my father
somewhere between me getting blown up
and getting to germany my dad was
notified about my injuries
seeing my father standing next to my
hospital bed and a sweat cake cowboy hat
purse on his head and cow [ __ ] likely
still on his boots gave me a much-needed
sense of normality and safety this was a
major surprise
dad it's good to see you my father gave
my leg a long look
then he gave me the usual tough but
correct opinion
well i figured if you played with fire
long enough you're going to get burnt
looks like you stepped on a doozy glad
you're alive son
from his demeanor one would think i'd
suffered a little more than a scratch
for the first month of my time at bamc
my father never left my hospital room on
the seventh floor
it was like he felt the need to be there
for me observing protecting and taking
everything in
my oldest sister chris who is my half
sister for my dad's first marriage was
also there
and you talk about the um just the
doctors and
the nurses and the health care providers
that are there and
what they're seeing every single
freaking day yeah how hard that is on
them
um you get your your lead doctor
a guy named dr sue
and he comes in and you're talking to
him the status of my right foot and leg
was still
uncertain i would lose the rest of my lo
would i lose the
less rest of my lower leg or was it
worth trying to keep the damn thing
dr sue never sugarcoated anything even
though at times i wish he would
i'll never forget one conversation we
have we have enough tissue
to do a limb salvage surgery he said
we'll do our best to reattach your foot
and lower leg but there are no
guarantees
because your leg is in bad shape we're
giving it a
10 to 15 chance for success
and if that doesn't work i asked we'll
have to amputate
but look on the bright side if this
works we will rewrite limb
salvage medical history well that was a
ray of hope
so do you think we should go ahead yes i
do but this will be a long
painful road it could be worth it in the
end so what do you think
i thought for a moment this was a big
decision
while i still have my leg i still have
options but at the moment
but the moment i have to cut it off
there's no going back i reasoned
you've been telling me that this will be
the hardest thing i've ever done but if
successful
doctors will use my case to redefine
limb salvage hell yeah i love a
challenge
let's do it
like paint a picture for me
uh what's connecting your right
lower leg to your rest of your body
so at that point in the hospital
i had um this it was called a um x-fix
it looks like this giant bird cage
and there's like 20 some odd rods that
they screw
into your bone so my so
you know obviously you need your you
need your tib your
tibula um but the fib they weren't
really worried about it and they said ah
the fib
doesn't really do much for you so we're
just gonna let that free float
okay fine but the tib so basically what
they did was they lined up
the tibula the best that they could
through the surgeries
screwed all of the rods into my bones
you know upper and lower
and i had i had rods going into my toes
it looked like something out of a saw
movie but and then
yeah they just they they uh they secure
everything together with
just all these rods going into your leg
and then the halo devices that attach
the rods
and then yeah the only way you can
really grow bone
is through friction and just beating the
crap out of yourself
in physical therapy and whatnot so
you know i had about two two inches
ish of uh tibula to grow back and so i
was
yeah i was about to do some uh yeah
some beat down sessions you know in
physical therapy to get that bone grown
so when when at like when it happened
you described there's just like a p
basically a piece of meat
keeping your leg how about nerves did
the nerves get damaged
yeah so even even right now i have um
i probably have half nerve function in
my leg
and then there's you know parts of my
leg that i just don't feel
at all and then there's other parts that
are
um hypersensitive and then and it's
it's crazy but but yeah my right leg is
this skin graft the bottom of my foot
this skin graft
it's yeah it's it's pretty uh
it's pretty it was it was pretty intense
but
medical technology did they graph the
skin on your bottom of your foot
uh so i have this dream i have this
dream that
i want to be able to kick somebody in
the face
because it's from my ass okay and then i
could
yeah does that does that
because i'm thinking is the skin that's
on the bottom of your foot
is that like does it did does it develop
calluses and everything now
like no no it's it's it'll never go past
the
newborn stage damn yeah so there's
yeah when i damage it it it's bad so
this
so this whole procedure was a was like a
freaking bottom of the ninth like just
last ditch effort hail mary i guess
we'll go football we'll go hail mary
scenario
yeah um well to save my leg it was
but for the surgeons because i you know
i remember doctor she was saying
i mean flat out he's like if you if it
doesn't work it's not like you had a leg
anyway so
you know you just move on and so um for
them it was an
it was an excellent opportunity to
to advance some you know technology with
lim salvage and whatnot like that and um
and yeah it's uh 2010 was an excellent
year to do it because there's a lot of
dudes getting blown up
lots of dudes
man that's um that's crazy
uh this is cool your your command
sergeant major
who you call brian brian was a man of
his word someone who put his men before
himself
he understood those under his command
took personal time to do what he could
to ensure each and every
man was taken care of he was a tough
leader who would crush you if you were
wrong
but he would go to hell him back to
defend any of his men
and you go into the book here one thing
among green berets is the willingness to
do anything to get back in the fight i
was no different toward the end of his
visit i asked brian the one question
that had been haunting haunting me for
weeks
i don't know what my future holds but i
will not let this injury beat me i fully
intend
on being a green beret and deploying
again if i can get myself healthy
will you send me back into the fight
brian looked at me like i had two heads
then glanced down on my right leg
he knew that he knew what was in the
heart of every green beret
but he had to drop some common sense on
me you're lucky to be alive ryan
let's figure out how to get you walking
again you've got a long road ahead of
you
relax and take it easy that wasn't
exactly the response i was hoping for
but hell
i knew i'd be lucky to walk unassisted
one day so maybe the chances of
returning to active duty as a green
beret were a little far-fetched
all it took was one look at my blown-up
leg and everyone knew this was something
that just wasn't going to happen but i
wasn't giving up
brian had my back but when i asked
anyone
in the hospital the same question i
heard something like this it's cool the
way you feel ryan
but you would be limping and in pain for
the rest of your life leave the fighting
to the young healthy guys
you've proven yourself enough but before
he left my sergeant major surprised me
brian leaned in looked me in the eye and
made me a promise
ryan if you can get medically cleared i
will send you back to afghanistan
yep check
uh that's awesome i don't think he quite
realized
you know what was uh i i talked and we
still keep in touch
now and it's you know it's hey man did
you do you guys think i was gonna
you know come back man it's
i mean no yeah i can't imagine he was
just
trying to sit you know hey yeah hey cool
yeah you i know you want to come back if
you can get healthy you come back but
really he's thinking i hope this guy
walks again yeah it was and and not
you know because i they did medically
retire me and i had to
you know fight back on active duty um
so but yeah it was uh it was one of
those situations and i remember um
i remember i had uh i forgot who he was
he
either no i don't know but um
one of the doctors he said hey look man
it's it's good to have goals
it is but your goals aren't realistic
you're setting yourself up for failure
because you're not going back
like this this is the doctor told you
this not dr shu but one of the other
doctors yes
another doctor that was a part of my um
therapy and whatnot
um and he and i understood where he was
coming from it's
expectation management you know um
and he said i my biggest concern is that
you set these goals up for yourself
and when they don't happen you can't
recover from
you know not uh achieving your goals
especially as a wounded guy because we
we all do it's
you know i i i don't think there's a
single military member in the united
states
um armed forces that got wounded and
didn't want to get back in the fight as
quick as they could
i mean there there probably is but i
don't know i don't think so yeah i've
never heard of one so
but yeah you just expectation management
you got to understand like
you can want it and it's a good drive
but man
it's you're you know you're you're in
you're in the bottom of our you're in
the bottom of the ninth just like you
said so
it's like you need to you need you need
to do some management expectation here
because
like start thinking about other things
start you know what are you going to do
with your life out of the military and
stuff like that
and i understood where he was going with
it because um
unfortunately a very bad statistic even
you know 2009 10 11 12 was um
wounded dudes dying you know committing
suicide what not and
and so they had to manage expectations
with guys because
yeah so i understood it um
the other the thing that you write about
in here is the like you're on
all these different drugs obviously for
pain killers and stuff but it seems like
that's just kind of sent you in
like real super emotional you'd be like
laughing then you'd be crying
sound like that was just freaking crazy
yeah yeah the
the drugs i was on i mean methadone for
one oh my gosh
it's i don't quite know what it would be
like to be a zombie but i'm pretty sure
i got a good idea from that drug
yeah methadone is a hell of a drug so
and that's what they used to get people
off of heroin
and you're just they had you on it for
pain obviously
yep so crazy
uh there's another
got another got another quote in here
from the old man we might have to get
the old man on the podcast
uh you know because you are you kind of
like rock bottom you're all freaking
emotional about everything and he says
look son you got dealt a bad hand
but this is a speed bump in life that's
all how you
handle this situation and pick yourself
up will determine how this affects you
later
as bad as it seems right now as dark as
the times appear to be
never forget that with time you will
heal and look back on this
please don't allow yourselves to look
back and feel ashamed
about how you dealt with this take
control of your life
own this situation turn it into
something good
learn about yourself in a positive way
and i promise you
in the end you will be a better man
dad's pep talk man pep talk meant the
world to me
i lay in my hospital bed that night and
vowed i would never become a victim of
life's circumstances i would use this
situation to make myself even stronger
i would face my demons which i had held
close for many years and defeat them
for years i had used my difficult
childhood as a crutch
after my father and mother divorced dad
had married two more times and always
seemed to find the bad ones
i did not trust women or really anyone
for that matter which i blamed on my
past
before i became a green beret i had two
failed marriages and it left a path of
destruction behind me but i always found
ways to rationalize my behavior it was
never my
fault i'm this way because i grew up
poor i'm this way because i had a shitty
childhood
i'm this way because life's not fair
everything was always
someone or something else's fault
i did not have control over my life life
controlled me even though my dad had
raised me right
there were some things you just had to
learn on your own the hard way
the saying what doesn't kill you makes
you stronger
seemed like the story of my life but it
didn't just happen on my own
i had to make the choice to become
stronger
that's when i determined i would use
this near-death experience to make
myself a better man
this will not beat me i will be the man
i was raised to be
i will take control of my life and
finally be responsible for my actions
even with this my come to jesus moment i
knew life wasn't going to get any easier
as a matter of fact the hard work was
just beginning
i'm going to take some ownership of
what's going on yep
your dad told you to own it yeah i
actually um
a lot of people don't understand this
when i say
when i say this but um stepping on that
ied actually saved my life
yeah and expand so
the path that i was heading down i was i
was going to
a point to where i couldn't return from
um just life controlled me a victim of
everything i was just
running you know i would destroy people
around me
instead of building them up i was not a
good person
um even with the victory of becoming a
green beret
i still hadn't i i still hadn't faced
any of my issues
i was just i was constantly running from
issues
and um and there was always i mean there
was
always something i was just i was weak
it was easy
to to uh blame somebody or something
or use the excuse of i mean you name it
and i came up with it
instead of taking i mean i'll use it
you trademark it but instead of taking
an extreme ownership of your life
i um you know i i allowed life to
to own me and it did and it did
and it wasn't until i stepped on that
ied
that i was actually able to get control
of my life again
what are the biggest things you what was
what was like the core
issue that you were running from what
like was pent up in you that made you
that you think like steered you in these
directions where you would be being a
tear
tear people down like what do you think
made you so kind of destructive
i hated myself i wasn't happy
um i didn't know how to like myself um i
didn't i
you know i always tried to live this
other people's lives thing
and you know i mean you see it today
it's it's rampant
where people they try and be something
that they're not they
they don't have their own identity and i
had no identity because what i was as a
person
was was ugly and destructive and i
didn't like myself
at all and so i technically i was always
running from myself
and the easiest way to do it is to take
a good situation
turn it into [ __ ] blame everybody else
for it tear people down around you
and then move on to the next
lately i've been thinking about this um
it's real easy when when you got an
opportunity when there's an opportunity
for you to do something
and you either fail or you're scared to
try
one of the easiest things to do is say
well that's not
cool or that's not important or that's
not for me
so it happens on every level right it
happens on every level when you know oh
you're not great you're not a great
runner well running
we should here's here's a classic
example in the seal teams
uh running right they're just running
like going for a run
and people that weren't good at running
would be like
running breeds cowardice meaning yeah
you know we're never gonna run
and it's a funny thing you know but
that's like a little bit of an example
of what we do as people of saying oh
well
uh school doesn't matter right when i
was a kid right school does
school stupid that was me all day long
when i was going to high school school
doesn't matter
why because i didn't want to try you
know i didn't want to put forth the
effort it's like oh so
therefore it doesn't matter and it's
something that we do
all the time and people do it with um
you know like hard work like starting a
business
hey i'm not i'm not i'm not into all
that material stuff
when really they just don't want to work
hard yeah so they cut it down
and they actually will detract from
people that are working hard
there's then you could say this about
really about anything right
and it seems like that's sort of that's
sort of it's not exactly what you're
saying but it's something that i've been
thinking about lately as i look at my
life and i'm like oh you know oh yeah
that doesn't really matter i'm like oh
wait a second does that really not
matter
or am i just am i just throwing that
thing out
because it's something that i don't want
to do or i'm afraid of
or i'm calling it not important because
oh oh really
okay well let's take a look at that
let's take a look at that
you look puzzled no no it's it's that's
interesting there that cause that's like
a level deeper than
like what's happening that's like kind
of like okay so you know what sour
grapes right you heard that before sour
expression so it's kind of the same wait
expand on sour grapes so i know your
definition okay so sour grapes is like
it's almost like jealousy almost but
so this is where the expression came
from i found out where there was this
fox
and he saw some grapes hanging on a vine
kind of high up he's like oh i'm gonna
jump up and eat those grapes
so he jumps up and he can't jump high
enough
so he's like all right whatever oh and
he tries again
still can't jump high enough he tries
one more time he's like i'm gonna get
him this time
they look delicious up there he jumps up
he can't get him and he's like ah those
grapes are probably
sour good anyway you know that's it and
leaves
so it's kind of that right it's
definitely kind of that yeah yeah
definitely kind of that i don't want it
you know i don't like that
yeah it's not important yeah sour
and if you let that if you if you
continually do that
if you continually to kind of shun and
turn your back on
everything that is a challenge
you know like you could have done this
like you know being in this freaking
special operations
you know after you after you didn't make
it through buds you'd be like
yeah opinion special be in the military
stupid right you could have done that
yeah you could done that all day long
be in the military stupid those guys are
freaking idiots i don't want to be
like you could you could have gone into
that mode and you just turn your back
and then you turn your back on something
else and you
and pretty soon you look around and
there's you're you're just you have
nothing left
right there's no that you've turned your
back on everything yep
it becomes a lifestyle and that's that's
when it's dangerous
and we've all we've all seen people
today that
they have shunned away from anything
that is that that they could possibly
fail at because of the fear of failure
that they i mean they
they've made that their life they are
that person now
and that's that's hard to come back from
you know what i really like about what
you just said
i really like the fact that you just
because you know everyone talks about
lifestyle
in like a positive thing like oh it's a
jiu jitsu lifestyle or it's a healthy
lifestyle or whatever and you're like oh
there's another lifestyle it's called
denial and making excuses that's a
lifestyle too and it's a shitty one that
leads to bad places
that's interesting that the tearing
other people down thing
where you know how you say it out loud
and it's like
well why would anyone do that like it's
so obvious
not to do that but i think when like
you're in it and you say
you hated yourself right where even
that's another one where it's like how
can you hate yourself
that doesn't even make sense right oh
that sounds like expression
right but in a way it's like literally
true
where if you if you don't like yourself
that makes you feel a certain way and
it's bad it's a bad feeling we'll say
put simply
so what kind of relief can you get
from that bad feeling is if you make
other people seem
less than and it kind of like relieves
you of that feeling just a little bit
you know
but not fully not even close to fully so
you constantly got to do it
to feel better about yourself
essentially yep it is um
it's it's a serious problem we yeah we
see it in our country
all the time right now i i think that's
actually what made me
start thinking about this because i'm
talking about oh
running is but you're what you're
talking about it's the same thing
when you look at another person instead
of going damn that person's really
accomplished a lot that's awesome
instead you say well i'm not going to be
some kind of career guy that's chasing a
promotion or
or yeah they just want to get all those
quals so they can look good
yeah you just throw all kinds of hate at
them yeah but the person that you really
hate
those are those are the excuses i'm
talking about is you
make up your own demise you make up your
own excuses
as to why that is not your path
and to basically you demonize that
person to make yourself feel better
even though um 90
screw it 100 of the time it's because
it's it's because you are afraid to fail
the
yeah yeah and it's weird when you start
looking at
like chunks of people that
look and say oh that lifestyle is bad
and it's like okay what are you really
mad about
someone that's working hard and trying
to be in good physical condition and
trying to learn and trying to grow like
there's people that look down on
all those things which is kind of crazy
when you think about it
yeah yep
all right uh hey tell us about the what
do you call the ideal breed
um brace or is it ideo like do you how
do you say that
yeah it's it so i called it an ideo i
did okay
but yeah basically it's uh it
uh ryan blanek he he created these
things
and um it um gives me a calf and
you know push uh you know i can i got
plant uh
i think whatever one goes down i don't
know but i
yeah i'm i'm sitting here trying to it's
like it's like an exoskeleton
type brace that you wear that makes up
for
whatever deficiencies you might have in
your movement
yes and so um it gives you know that
that basically
it's it gives you your life back and
that's what allows you to
keep your leg that's what allows you to
not have to go through the prosthetic
is because now you have this um this
uh i'm not even going to try and say the
name but it's it's long
the uh you mean the intrepid dynamic
exoskeleton
orthosis that that's what i was going to
say
i understand do you wear do you have to
wear that thing all the time so i've
actually gotten to a point
now to where i've rebuilt back my leg
to where i only use that if i'm doing
anything
physical like jim um i'll have my ideo
on
or deployment i'll wear the idea or
whatnot but
um here um i know i came here without it
on
i didn't and you're walking around i
mean you you walking totally normal
walking upstairs downstairs i mean it's
awesome to see yeah and
yeah until until you uh until you get
caught on that one thing and
it's that's funny and that's because you
have no nerves or
do you have like drop foot no um i
i don't have drop foot it's kind of
naturally has fused itself
at the the l okay yeah so
but you know you can catch yourself and
yeah it's it's
i think it's funny i don't know what is
drop foot like that like
the nerve that makes you lift up your
foot gets damaged
and so your foot just kind of down yeah
yeah the
yeah it did it had naturally fused at
the ankle joint so
um that nerve is gone but it's just the
foot just stays at an add an l
and andy stumpf has a certain amount of
dropped foot and from when he got shot
he like lost
some he got some he got a bunch of
injuries but he got some nerve damage
and so his foot doesn't respond
really the way he wants it to and he
makes some pretty funny jokes about that
it's kind of funny uh so the army wanted
to medically retire you mm-hmm
at this point and and then they offered
you kind of something called
continuation on active duty
which means you basically they're still
going to give you your paycheck and
you're going to use some kind of an
admin job for your
to get to 20. yep yeah so i was
medically retired
and then i applied for the waiver which
was the continuation on active duty
waiver
and i got picked up for that how many
years had you been in at this point
total air force navy and army 12
ish yeah something like that so
you now did you is that a document that
you like signed do you accept that or
did you fight it
um the medical retirement well the
medically retired medical retirement you
you obviously fought yeah i mean that
that was
so i was medically retired and then i
came back onto active duty through a
waiver
got it so they medically retired you and
then you came back on
when you came back on did you have that
limited duty thing the the
the continuation on active duty is that
how you came back on yeah and
basically what it is so they do it for
um green berets seals
raiders all kind of stuff if they they
spent that kind of money
training you up we can find something
for you yeah absolutely no
it's an awesome program and it's a good
way to take care of
take care of people yep then you find
out about this program called
four three yeah and so tell us about
that thor 3 program so
i think uh i think the seals i think you
guys kind of have something similar the
return to fight program yeah we got all
we got awesome
people that are just doing everything
they can to keep guys ready and if they
get hurt to get them back in the fight
yep it's awesome
yep um so it's basically that we call it
the re uh
the return to fight or the road to war
program or whatever
and um man it's hard i mean they bring
these guys in from
you know they were physical physical
trainers for
you know hockey teams or whatnot or like
um paul
uh he was he he worked um he was on tito
ortiz's um
group and paul did all of the athletic
training for him so
yeah you're not really going to tell him
like it's kind of hard
he's like oh that's cute so and um
and i i just i knew you know i
had gotten myself back to seventh group
but i had a dead man's profile
so i knew for me for seventh group to
wave
um big army's profile um i would have to
i would have to tear up dudes in in the
thor 3 program and um
and so i just you know i i was on this
path of you know i
i was getting i was racking up victories
in my life and um
and so the thor 3 program is it was
tough
it was extremely hard but guys that had
never been hurt before
um i was just you know with all the
physical events and everything like that
just leaving them in the dust
but you know they weren't really
fighting for anything i was i was trying
to get back to war
so um
and then you you end up pulling it off
man yeah
yeah uh here you go after a few months
of working with it with a thor 3 program
building up my body and rehabbing my
sore right leg
impressing my pts on how far i'd come my
command gave me some great news i was
good to deploy
when seventh group would take full
responsibility for me
my waiver was signed i was jacked from
the moment i got the word from brian
that if i could get healthy enough he
would send me back i had only one goal
in my head to return to combat
this was why i put in all the hard work
i didn't want to be cooped up in some
cubicle reading reports
and looking at the clock counting down
the hours until i would call today i
want to be conducting missions with the
guys
doing what i was trained to do taking
the fight to the enemy my company had
already left for afghanistan
but once i got the medical waiver signed
by seventh group lead surgeon
i was on the next flight out april 2012.
i would be deployed to the panz y
is that right uh panjiway panjway
district in kandahar province in
southern afghanistan
known as the birthplace of the taliban
times couldn't have been tenser
in the area so there you go man
yeah yeah i got my wish returned
returned to war
and then uh i got sent to the uh the
most heavily ied
area in afghanistan in 2012 bro this is
this is freaking all right so here we go
uh
you're you're you get sent to the most
heavily ied
place i was reading this i was like
all right i'll just read it so here we
go you're on you're on a
real really hard patrol to get to where
you're going to get to the target area
you're the freaking point man again
by the way the last time you were a
point man you you got freaking blown up
yeah you start you start clearing this
compound
again this is like deja vu
back to the book we were barely underway
when one of my afghan special forces
soldiers
and i detected our first ied in a
partially collapsed outside wall
of the first compound there it was
buried in the dirt and surrounded by
rubble
from a break in the wall that was likely
caused by a previous id blast or an rpg
strike a nice little ied
all you had to do is trip this sucker
all you had to do to trip the sucker
was step on the pressure plates that
connected the positive wires to the
negative
once the circuit was completed boom the
charge went off and your life was
changed forever
welcome back to afghanistan the taliban
had figured we would take this route
because it was a shortcut into the
compound i have to admit that finding my
first ied since nearly losing my life
especially a nasty one like this
produced a whole range of emotions
my heart was racing but i had to keep it
together because my team was watching
really you have to admit that you had
some some emotions bro
uh first i slowly pushed the dirt away
exposing the corners of the pressure
plate i steadied my hands and searched
for the arming wires when i uncovered
them
i traced the wires to a battery pack
hidden behind some rocks
then i disconnected the power source and
clamped surgical clamps to the wire
my surgical clamps were attached to a
50-foot nylon cord so i could get some
standoff
or safe distance before pulling out the
pressure plate
after moving the team back i got my 50
feet of standoff and gave the cord a
pull
the pressure plate came flying through
the air the first step was complete
but the ied was not completely disarmed
i then attached my cord to a plastic
yellow jug buried beneath the pressure
plate
and returned my to my 50-foot withdrawal
distance
after a tug-of-war match with the jug i
was finally able to yank it out of the
ground crap
this was a 15-pound ied more than enough
to kill you
or blow off both your legs how come i
didn't just safely blow up the ied
which is exactly what i was asking the
normal procedure is when you find a
freaking ied you put some explosives on
you blow that thing up blow in place
bip yep um usually when i come across an
idea
i expose part of the pressure plate to
verify it was natural explosive
then i would place a half block of c4 on
it and blow it in place
but we were trying to track down the ied
makers in our area i decided to disarm
the ied instead of blowing it up
because of the increased pressure we
were getting to collect evidence
which was key to finding the culprits
with this first ied out of the way
i breathed the deep psi relief things
had gone well and it almost felt like i
knew what i was doing
better yet i gave my teammates a warm
fuzzy feeling about my capabilities and
showed them that i could be an asset
rather than a liability on the
battlefield
why did i deal with the ied instead of
directing one of our afghan counter ieds
to get on it
you could call me stupid or crazy but i
wanted to get some
ieds under my belt
okay i mean i you're not stupid so i
guess we're going with crazy
and i i guess you want to get some ideas
under your belt is better than getting
ids under your foot
yeah i yeah i think i think my mindset
at that time was
um very i mean could have been
pretty deemed as pretty reckless but i i
just and
that was the first one i came in contact
with and i was going to own it
yeah that just kind of that's the choice
i made
um if i was to go back i would stick
half block c4 on it and move back
uh and that's what you're doing man id
after id cache after cache every time
we'd go out on a mission
one thing was certain is the sun coming
up in the morning we'd run into some
sort of explosive device
made to kill or maim us and you know i i
skipped through the part where you kind
of like we're checking back in with the
team and these guys are thinking hey can
this guy really do his job and he's
already how scared is he going to be
how bad is his leg he's out here with a
freaking brace on his leg what kind of
you know so you had to kind of push
through all that i kind of skipped
through it but it's a really interesting
part of the book as well
yeah i mean and and that's the thing is
i've i've had
i've heard people's reaction to it
they're like oh well that's that's
that's just so messed up
and it's like it's not that's special
operations
when you go out to the team being in war
isn't a make-a-wish foundation kind of
thing
like oh you know here's our make-a-wish
foundation green beret we're going to
take them out on some missions no people
people can die and um and so i
understood completely
like they knew what had happened to me
most of the team was on the battlefield
that day
in the hellman saw my leg
and so for me to get back out to the
team
in the most heavily ied area in
afghanistan at that point
i i don't blame him like what are you
doing here dude like you have no
business being out here
but you got to prove it another cool
i'm not going to read the whole section
but you're talking about like what
you're looking for
and one thing you said is you were you'd
you'd be looking and you'd be thinking
would i put an ied there if i was a bad
guy that was kind of the perception you
looked at everything with
oh yeah i get asked this question a lot
about um
how do i find ieds and they're like oh
you have a mine detector mine detector
doesn't really do anything
for me i look at so i i take a breakdown
of the battlefield or
the objective that we're going on to and
then i look at
okay so the easiest avenues of approach
they're going to be ieds there
you've got a 12-foot mud hut wall and
there's a break in the wall right here
and then it's 12 feet again there's
going to be an ied there
and then i also um so before i even
use my mine detector i i get ground sign
ground sign tells me everything and then
i verify it with my mind detector
and then i i mean i've i've i've
definitely come up to
like breaks in the wall and whatnot and
i don't even use my mind detector or
anything i just put a block of c4 there
get back and
yeah because there's gonna be one there
and so
how much of uh how much do you think
like
one thing i was always paranoid about
was like oh they've got the fake ied
there
and they did this in ramadi a lot like
oh there's a wire and whatever
and someone goes over to disarm it and
they step on something else and get
blown up yep the decoys
yeah oh the decoys are nasty super nasty
and that
that goes back to that you know that
saying that we've all had and i
guarantee you guys probably said it in
ramadi
was um where there's one there's five um
you know if
i you know where there's one there could
be ten or what but
where there's one there's gonna be
secondary because when that guy hits one
of them
then the rescue team's gonna come in and
they're gonna start hitting the
secondaries or we're going to use one as
a decoy
and then we're pretty sure we can funnel
with this decoy here
now i can funnel the troop movement this
way and then
it's all ied yeah and my point of
bringing that up is like
it's a it's it's not checkers it's not
like oh there's an obvious place there's
an ied
it's chess where it's like oh there's
one there but that means they're
probably thinking we're going to move
over there so the place we really need
to watch out for it
so the taliban are super good at that
crazy good at trying to anticipate troop
movements
and then ieds you're carrying on with
the
deployment months go by and
at one point you're in a little bit of a
fire fight
and you you step into basically
uh a [ __ ] ditch and it's filled with
[ __ ]
it's filled with human sewage which is
which sucks because it stinks and it's
gross and all that but the real problem
is
you got your you know your foot which is
a bunch of skin grafts is in there and
this is after a long patrol so
you already got blisters and whatnot
because you got freaking baby skin on
the bottom of your foot
yeah open blisters so
that is a problem yeah i mean we
uh we got we gotten a bit of a tick and
every every war fighter knows cover and
then
return fire um violence of action
everything like that
to you know get control of the situation
again
and so i remember you know we're we're
engaging you know different targets
and i was you know my my adrenaline was
really high
but it still is man something really
stinks here i was like what in the heck
is this and i just and then finally once
you know it's like all right we got
aircraft on station which means bad guys
are gone
um so then i start to kind of get a
sense of my surroundings and
as a [ __ ] trench and i was up to my uh
my calves
and and so all of the open sores that i
had where my skin grafts were
um just human feces going in
yeah so you get an infection
um and you're worried like you're gonna
get sent home
but it turns out they don't they don't
send you home dude yeah go ahead
uh no yeah they my team you know when we
got back
you know i basically i had to tell our
delta you know because it was bad he's
man
you need to go to caf and then when i
got to caf
they basically said they're like okay
you're done in the panzerway we need to
monitor
you um we don't you know we're not sure
if you're going to redeploy back to the
states or not i knew if i redeployed
back to the states that was a death wish
as in and i don't mean literally but as
in
the command will know that this gamble
that they took to let me go back to war
um it didn't pay off and i would never
see combat again
and so i uh i i found work
um i carried heavy [ __ ] and i made
myself
a an important part of that and this was
the first time in my life and so again
it sounds really weird but stepping in
this
you know knee deep or i'm sorry calf
deep and human feces
led up to the first time in my life
instead of saying poor me this happened
to me
why did i jump in that one trench and
everything like that
i owned it and i went and i found work
and i and i made myself this valuable
asset on calf loading helicopters to
send supplies out to the guys in the
field
um you know and still in combat and i i
made you know
made a name for myself as always getting
these guys the stuff they needed and
whatnot like that so
i found work and yeah and that was the
first time that
like that was a major victory for me of
taking control over
something that i very easily in the past
what a straight went into
victimization
so that you're how long are you doing
that job for um
i was doing that for
probably the last three months of the
deployment
um and then you do you end up
healing up decently and there's one more
there's there ends up being a mission
and the mission
is is uh to go set up there's a big
mission going on but you're gonna go
with the command element you're gonna
set up a command
post on the top of a hill and that means
you're going to get inserted and you're
going to have to walk
two kilometers but with 3 000 feet of
elevation gain
and it it's it's a it's a tough mission
it's a physically tough mission you have
some other strap hangers with you
one of those guys wants to quit one of
the other guys you guys end up having to
carry other people's gear on that
um but you do it yeah you do it you do a
good job
you're healed up and luckily on the
mission uh you know it's a it's a
relatively
peaceful mission yeah we uh we were
supporting
so the uh the seals and a bunch of odas
we were clearing this valley together it
was a joint mission
and um in the command element last
mission of the deployment
command element wants to get you know
boots on the ground say they did
something
and so yeah we yeah we were going up to
hilltop 2000 and guys you know one guy
he just
flat out i mean sorry but quit
and i was like i didn't think he could
do that in combat yeah
this is not training bro there's no
training time out here and then another
guy his body just failed him and so we
were whole
we were carrying all this stuff up to
the top but i'm not
big on spotlight ranger kind of stuff
but i knew
for sure that i could solidify
my career as a green beret if the
colonel
and the command sergeant major all saw
me as a beast
even though my body was that's
that was another time when i learned
like your mind quits
way before your body will way before
your body will
and if you have if you if you put this
drive you you have this goal you want to
reach and that goal
is more important to you than your mind
giving up on you then you will be able
to see
how much further you can actually go
once your mind has told you you're done
yeah i
sometimes people like oh what do you do
when you get like what do you tell
yourself when you're when you
don't want to do something and i'm like
i don't tell myself anything because my
mind is the one
i'm just gonna go i'm gonna keep doing
what i'm doing like i don't have these
negotiations with myself about like well
you should really no i'm like shut up
keep going
there's the answer yeah yeah and it's
it's hard until you make it a lifestyle
yeah yeah that's the positive lifestyle
we're looking for
uh you get done with that mission
you you know a little while later you go
back to america when you get back to
america
you actually go into the normal seventh
group rotation
which seventh groups ao is
south america yep south central america
south and central america
so you end up doing some do you call
them deployments if they're
if they're short what do you call those
um so we we have uh cnts
or um jsets and i know um
seals you guys do json yep um you also
do cnts that counter narcotic yeah
okay so it's the same thing because we
um i remember
all of my deployments down south central
america there was always
seal platoons there so so you do some of
those
shorter trips and you go to el salle you
go to colombia you go to peru
and then i think you were getting ready
to deploy
to guatemala and all of a sudden
things change yeah they had um
they requested so bravo company second
battalion was heading back to
afghanistan
short on guys and um so i saw
i saw my in right there and i i started
creating
you know ways of finding my way over to
afghanistan
somehow and that was that was all it
took was
i just i i gave him the sales pitch
and the original answer to your sales
pitch was cool you can come but you're
going to be
not you know not not a shooter yeah i
was going to be riding a desk and
managing um uh
right just sources right right
um so you so you're doing that that's
your plan is to go over there
uh you show up and uh
about a month after you're there you get
approached by the ops
sergeant who says a new mission just got
dropped in our laps you want a piece of
the action
uh and you say yep and so you guys start
planning this mission
uh going to the book here the way we
drew things up the taliban would see the
afghan commandos heading into the
village and fire at them knowing for
certain that the afghan soldiers would
turn and run away like they had many
times before
once a bunch of taliban [ __ ] started
shooting however that would be all we
needed to call in close air support
assets overhead
which would give the taliban a healthy
taste of american firepower
the insurgents would know in a new york
minute that the americans were in the
fight
and that would change the battlefield in
a hurry
and then you say on paper everything
read well
and i i put a nice little exclamation
point by that
because as we know things that look good
on paper
don't always turn out the way you expect
them to nope
um you proceed into this
i'm gonna fast forward a little bit um
you're you're now executing the mission
i could see our first target compound
which was about 100 meters up the path
still had a long distance to clear and
again this is after
you you insert on the mission when you
get done playing the mission you insert
the mission you're moving
you're moving to this first area that
you're going to clear
and the path started to narrow
and rows of dormant fruit trees
swallowed up the ground as we patrolled
deeper into the orchard
i reminded myself to concentrate on
significant details that were almost
impossible to see under night vision
and then pop what the [ __ ] was that we
all hit the ground unsure of the loud
snap we just heard was it a gunshot
sniper's in the area
we waited for a [ __ ] storm of bullets to
rain down on us but nothing happened
then i noticed that ja weed is that
right yup joey jawed
and i were tangled in some type of line
almost like fishing line
holy [ __ ] we had hit a tripwire ied
that didn't explode how did i miss that
as jaw weed carefully investigated the
tripwire against his chest without any
quick movements i determined that the
taliban
had tied the wire that ran from the set
of explosives hidden in a mud wall
all the way to a tree on the opposite
side of the path the wire had been tied
at chest level
not the usual ankle height a clever move
on the taliban's part
they knew we would be looking at our
detectors to clear which meant we would
be looking
down at the dirt and walk right into a
chest level
tripwire why didn't the ied go off
the best explanation i could come up
with was that the when the overwatch
element laid waste for five minutes
firing everything they had into the
orchard
fragmentation from one of the mortars
had hit the ied and disabled it luck was
on our side so
there you go you're walking through this
freaking orchard you hit a
wire and for whatever reason probably
the the
preparatory fire that had been fired by
your team
had disrupted the ied yep
we had cleared another 15 meters of path
when i saw
movement in an open field near the first
compound
i turned to abe and abe is one of your
guys that you had with you
one of your one of your afghans that you
had with you
and that was when all hell broke out
before abe could respond the night was
lit up by a barrage of gunfire coming
from the compound's outer wall first it
was a zip zip zip followed by the crack
of 762
caliber rounds flying past our heads
these rounds which ripped holes in the
darkness
looked like a laser light show with
tracer streaking across the night sky
next came an explosion from an rpg being
fired at us
then more automatic fire we had walked
directly into an ambush
[ __ ] with my heart beating out of my
chest i hit the ground and started
returning fire
the taliban the taliban had set up a
complex ambush
ambush and the tripwire ied was supposed
to start the whole thing off
one of their pkm machine guns let out a
burst of 20 meters a burst of fire 20
meters from our position
a distance so close that it was almost
like i could grab the flame coming out
of the
end of the barrel jawed abe and buzmala
how do you say that
uh bes besmiela bismullah jumped into
the ditch
while kahan khan khan okay just khan
while khan darted back and took cover
behind a tree
i hit the deck and lay as flat as i
could in the middle of the dirt
path bullets kicked up and rock and
gravel fragments all around me stinging
my skin
when bullets hit the ground around me
splintering fragments
sprayed everywhere i could tell some
fragments struck my body armor's
protective plate
i was engaged i engaged the flames
figuring that where there were flames
there was a gun
and where there was an ak-47 there was a
fighter
ryan your strobe light my buddy zack
yelled over the radio
they have nvgs they can see your strobe
damn bro what were you thinking when you
heard that
all right i need to get this off my
helmet
i need to get this ir strobe away from
me
and our jtac couldn't see me because
we'd get caught up in an l-shaped ambush
and um and so he wasn't sure where the
pkm was
and that's you know so i i took it off
my helmet and
i threw it as close as i could to where
that pkm was at
and then just hit the deck again and
started engaging muzzle flashes
and the could the jtac want you through
the ir could he see it
could the jtac see it so it was kind of
funny um
so i said you know you guys have visual
on the ir
and yeah and go okay they're they're
over that direction he goes
what you know i don't know so
uh
going back here you're there there's one
guy that starts peeking out
um and you you actually end up
killing this guy the third time he came
out he took more time in the previous
two
two tries attempting to a better shot
off at us it was like he was daring me
to light his ass up i knew i had him
i locked in with a clear shot and let go
a 10 to 15 round burst from my m4
i watched him drop his body lay still on
the ground it felt good to kill him but
i couldn't relish the moment too long
we were still pinned down our main
element which was about 25 to 30 meters
behind our position
put as much firepower on the enemy as
they could hoping to keep their heads
down long enough for us
aircraft to start dropping bombs i knew
from the many fights i'd been
in before in this country that a call
for air support
had been made within seconds of their
attack in the meantime
frankie's position let loose this is one
of the other team teammates
but the taliban were well protected
behind mud walls unless they stepped out
of the open like the guy with the rpg
launcher
there wasn't much we could do without an
airstrike at the same time
i was aware given how close we were to
the enemy that being killed by friendly
fire
was a very real worry
yeah so you're you're 15 to 20 meters
away from these bad guys
yes the first pkm and
just so anyone that's wondering um
15 to 20 meters is not a long way when
you're gonna try and drop
bombs uh yeah there's danger close and
then there's dr
calling in on your position and it's
yeah
it's a little dicey this is getting a
lot dicey yeah
yet as our situation deteriorated by the
second i knew that without bombs on
target
jawed abe bismullah khan and i
would all die this was about to turn
into a body recovery mission
and it would be our bodies that would be
that they would be taking home
within a couple of minutes the decision
was made for us when our
air force jay talk jtac called in a 500
pound bomb
just 20 meters from my position this was
considered a danger close
strike i don't even know if that's
considered danger that's that's called
on
my position yeah especially 500 pounds
uh this was considered a danger close
strike but one that would give us a
fighting chance of making it out of the
orchard alive the call went out over the
radio and then i heard
air force jtac's voice in my earpiece
ryan we're dropping close to you man
keep your [ __ ] head down after
receiving the radio transmission i
relayed the information to abe who told
the others to get as low as they could
there wasn't enough room in the ditch so
i grabbed khan and pushed him into the
trench while i stayed on the footpath
i ordered them to hunker down and
prepare for the blast since we weren't
firing back at the enemy
the volume of fire on our position
picked up so now you guys are
hunkering down because you're expecting
this bomb and now these the enemies
thinking they got an upper hand overhead
i could hear the rocket motors of the
f-16
ripping through the sky as the
fighter jet came inbound i received one
last warning over the radio
bombs away man stay low i lay as flat as
i could on the path holding my hands
over my head and planting my face in the
dirt
then i slightly tilted my head and
opened my mouth to give the over
pressure or shock wave a place to exit
all i could do was wait for the blast
when the bomb hit the over
pressure from the explosion sent grass
dirt gravel dust and tree branches
flying in our direction
i waited for the big chunks of mud of
the mud compound to land on me as well
as bits of earth and other debris
thankfully i was spared from the hunks
of mud wall hitting me which would have
broken my back
instead i was covered with dirt leaves
and branches but the concussive force
was so great that i felt like my
skeleton had just walked out of my body
turned slapped me in the face and
re-entered my body
i tried to stand up i kept falling i
almost felt like i was drunk yeah if you
have a 500 pound bond go off
freaking you're rocked yeah it's like
you just got
like when you see someone get knocked
out in the in in the ufc
that's what you just got hit with yep
only
not just to the jaw but to the entire
body
in all my time in afghanistan i'd get to
experience a concussive explosion of
that magnitude it took a good minute to
regain my senses just as i was figuring
out what happened
i heard my guys screaming over the radio
ryan are you good ryan answer your
[ __ ] radio if you're alive
their voices sounded like someone's
yelling down a long tunnel trying to get
my attention
i got my bearings [ __ ] that was good
that was big
big but i'm good man i answered i
couldn't believe what had just happened
how big of a bomb was that 500 pounds
brother you just ate a big one man
and i'm still alive i thought i had come
away without a scratch until i felt warm
liquid coming out of my ears from the
monstrous blast
damn that was close there was no time to
worry about my
the ear drip because i had no idea if
the enemy was still moving around or all
tapped out
i took a moment to shake the cobwebs out
of my head then i checked on my guys to
ensure they were good
after everyone was accounted for
uninjured i had my guys fall back to the
closest position
which was 20 meters behind us once we
were back with the main element
our jtac called in another strike which
would ensure that if anyone was still
moving in the compound
they were sure to be dead
damn that's uh
that's freaking psycho crazy right there
he's dropping a 500 pound bomb at 20
meters like i said that's
i mean we'll have to ask a good deal
dave burke
and see what the you know what what the
error box is on that
yeah you know i were you a jtac i was a
jtac in
like 20 meters is tight
that's a tight one but they do it that's
what they do you know they got gps
guided munitions and they do
they do drop them right into a spot yeah
they actually had to switch out
aircraft or switch out platforms um to
drop
a non-fragmentation producing like a
concussion oh
wow because of how close we were and it
took like five minutes to get bombs on
target
and anyone who's been in a tick before
five minutes yeah
a really long time well salute to your
jtac because that's a ballsy call right
there
yep he's uh freaking legit yeah i
remember him saying he was like man if i
if i would have killed you my career is
done i was like thank you
don't worry about your bro yeah the
deeds amazing saved my life oh yeah for
sure that's crazy
you know that's uh when i was a jtac
they would when you had to call danger
close you have to give your initials i
don't know if they still do this
but you have to give your initials
saying like i'm signing for this bomb
this is on me and you need to drop this
bomb and you like they would be
authenticate with you or jtac initials
or something i forget the actual
calls but the update juliet whiskey drop
it and then boom
um so you now you go
you you go you clear this compound um
the sun's starting to come up
it's kind of settled down the
situation's kind of settled down a
little bit
the sun start to come up you're feeling
good about that because now
it makes ieds easier to find
um then you start moving
to another compound and and once again
you're just like
finding ids tripping ids and still just
moving from compound to compound
clearing more ieds
as you enter these other compounds
there's there's not any movement or
anything
you say during the rest of our clearance
i encountered more than
20 ieds i personally blew up 15 before i
ran out of c4
explosives we marked the rest
overall we located more than 50 ieds
470 107 millimeter rockets
multiple booby traps and a complex
bunker and tunnel system
this this particular part of the village
lived up to its reputation as a hotbed
for taliban fighters
the taliban had reinforced bunkers
spread throughout the village many
connecting with tunnels
that's freaking psycho i mean running
into 50 ieds
carrying them all yeah it's um
yeah the ones we couldn't clear we just
had to mark and bypass
it was yeah that village was uh super
nasty super nasty
so then there's this little discussion
between the afghan force leader
who after you guys clear these places
your
the goal is hey the afghans stay there
to
you know prohibit the taliban from
coming in and taking over
so there's a little bit of a discussion
because
you know american forces are going to
leave like okay we did the hard part
and we cleared everything now you stay
there and occupy and build defenses and
set up claymores and you know secure the
area and hold on to it
well they don't want to do that and so
this discussion is happening
and uh while this discussion is
happening which by the way your team
leader says
the afghan says uh the americans should
say not my afghan soldiers
you're better equipped to fight the
taliban and the team leader says if this
was texas i would agree with you but
we're in afghanistan
this is your country i'm here to help
you but not win your battles
yeah uh so as this little discussion's
going on
one of your afghan one of the afghan
commandos comes up to you and
and with with the interpreter and says
there's 15 to 20 men moving our way
yep and you know the discussion still
going on
a few seconds later the afghan commando
tugged on my shirt
sleeve to get my attention again the men
are heading this way
we need to do something because i don't
think these are villagers from the area
he said i went back to my team sergeant
was more direct we need to get out of
here
we have fighting age males moving in our
direction i'm grabbing my guys and
getting into positions to move out
the team sergeant now nodded [ __ ] this
he said i'm done negotiating with these
guys let's move out
he had barely finished this sentence
when the first shot whizzed by my head
with the all too familiar zip followed
by a crack
we were immediately in the fight for our
lives
rounds were coming in all around
from automatic machine gun fire a series
of rpg explosions took us by total
surprise
everything turned into total chaos in an
instant everything was happening so fast
it was impossible for the human brain to
comprehend it
instinctively i knew i was sprinting for
cover but for a split second i felt
frozen in pandemonium of everything
happening around me
while my brain scrambled to make sense
of the attack's ferocity
now i was moving quickly screaming
instructions and returning fire to an
enemy
i could not see rounds sprayed
everywhere hitting compound walls like a
garden hose watering down a dusty road
just then i heard abe grunt as if he was
hurt that was
that's one of your afghans but for some
reason it didn't occur to me that he
could have been hit
i darted toward a ditch that paralleled
the dirt road running through the
village
after diving for cover i peered out
cautiously but i couldn't see any of my
guys
or where we were taking fire from
bullets were tailing up dirt all around
me as we tried to stay as low as
possible
then i noticed that three commandos in
the ditch 10 meters from my position
had drawn the attention of a taliban
machine gun crew that had zeroed in on
them
i waved for the three afghans to move to
my position which would give them more
cover
but they were too scared to move i knew
that if they didn't get their asses in
gear and start moving they were gonna
die
i don't know what possessed me but i
climbed out from my ditch and sprinted
to their position
praying to god that my adaptive leg
would hold up
i reached the first commando and grabbed
the very first thing that i could get a
hold of his hair
i yanked him out up and pulled him back
to my ditch hoping the other two would
follow
they did as we ran dust kicked up and
more rounds impacted around us
i slid into the ditch like i was legging
out a triple then i reached back and
dragged the three scared shitless
commandos down with me we had company in
this part of the ditch frankie was
providing aid to another wounded afghan
frankie you okay man i'm good brother
how about you yeah i'm okay
you see abe or anyone else not yet man
i moved closer to a small mud wall that
paralleled the ditch this wall provided
decent protection from enemy fire and
allowed me to look down the dirt road
where i saw an afghan soldier
lying motionless i brought up my rifle
scope to get a better look
frankie i think that's bizmula in the
middle of the road bro i think he's dead
my heart jumped straight to my throat
one of our guys was killed [ __ ] where's
the rest of my team
frankie and i were the only two
americans in that ditch
i scanned back down the road where
bismillah lay
i knew abe was next to him before the
ambush kicked off but i could only see
bismullah
i hoped abe wasn't hit too what i could
determine
was that we had two wounded afghan
commandos and bismullah
lying in the middle of the road i
figured bismillah was dead
but until i had my hands on him i
couldn't be 100 sure
i knew i needed to get to him but the
amount of live fire coming in was too
heavy
the radio crackled again and then i
heard a heart-stopping message
in my headset loud and clear
eagles down eagles down
the phrase eagles down was code for
americans wounded or killed
the fight had just taken the worst
possible turn
there were americans wounded or killed
somewhere on the battlefield
but i didn't know where we needed some
air support
in a hurry
how much time has passed and what i just
read and i skipped a little bit of stuff
but
this is all i remember a few minutes
no i remember we were
basically screaming for air support and
they couldn't because
the taliban with the tunnel systems they
were in our lines
and they couldn't drop because they
couldn't distinguish who was who
and so yeah it became a fist fight at
that point
here's the understatement of the year
coming from you back to the book
bro this [ __ ] is bad i said to frankie
no sooner did the words leave my lips
then i heard one sound that gives every
green beret chills
an explosion from a mortar round which
landed 30 meters from us
and shook the earth i hit the ground and
turned toward frankie [ __ ] i yelled
they got a mortar tube up we need to
move before we get hit
so for anyone that doesn't know anything
about mortars
when you shoot mortars you don't hit
what you're aiming at on the first shot
usually you have to do something called
bracketing which means you fire your
first shot
and oh it goes long so you back your
distance off a little bit you fire your
next shot
it's probably going to be short and then
you split the difference and your next
shots are on target
so when you're getting mortared if you
sit there they're going to bracket you
they're going to find you and they're
going to get you
gun fire is one thing if the enemy is
close enough to shoot at you he's close
you're close enough to kill him mortars
are different
they can be two or three kilometers away
and engage you with deadly fire and by
the time you figure out where they're
coming from it's too late
another explosion hit the compound to
the left of us too close for comfort
that was our cue time to make a move
frankie and i engaged taliban targets as
much as possible trying to keep their
heads down with return fire
which would give us a little time to
pick up our wounded afghans and move
back
crack a round hit directly into the wall
above my head crack another round too
close for comfort
crack and another one then two more
rounds hit the mud wall in front of us a
sniper had our position dialed in
every time we stuck our heads up he sent
rounds our way to make matters worse the
taliban were dropping mortars closer and
closer to our position
one of the afghan commandos besides us
spoke a little english he pointed to his
radio and said he heard the taliban
had our position and were trying to
capture us
hearing that word struck fear in my
heart i nudged frankie again
the taliban are trying to flank us and
cut us off from the rest of our guys so
they can take us
it's time to move brother i shouted
first things first how do we avoid
getting shot by the sniper i saw a
protected area near a compound
a couple of hundred meters from us where
i recognized several americans including
our medic joe
frankie i see joe let's move to him
so you guys gather everyone up and you
finally like are able to get
over to this other position where joe is
joe's your medic he's working on guys uh
you get their all blood moans and cries
for help
state of shock could be seen on the
commandos faces we knew we were in a
real [ __ ] storm
so far we had one dead afghan commando
two wounded afghans
three wounded americans we were missing
five
afghans including abe and bismullah
who are your two guys yes
and still no air support um at that
point in time
once we were able to get back to the ccp
well the first ccp
um we were able to start dropping bombs
on on the targets probably 45 minutes
into the tick
and then um they came up out of tunnels
and engaged us at that first ccp which
means we had to find another ccp
how are you doing for ammo we're
handing mags off yeah
so you're in this first casualty
collection point ccp so for those who
don't know this is
when you're in a bad situation and
you've got casualties you want to get to
a point where you can gather all the
casualties together
so you can number one provide security
number two provide medical attention and
then number three
try and figure out where you're
tactically can get them out of there
so you're in this ccp i looked around
for jawed and khan
jawed was sitting up against the wall
trying to catch his breath grabbing dost
our interpreter
i asked him if he knew where abe was
jawed shook his head no i haven't seen
abe
just then i saw frankie khan and two
afghan commandos
carrying bismullah from the road to the
ccp
bismillah is alive but he can't feel his
legs frankie said
thank god we got biz but where's abe i
asked
a puzzled look came over frankie no one
has seen abe since the firing started
bro he's still out there
fast forward a little bit now that we
had most of our friendly forces back in
one location our aircraft could start
engaging targets up first was the white
two-story former school building and
these are things you explain
these are areas where you're taking fire
from after 45 minutes of intense
fighting we finally dropped our first
bomb
as the f-15 jet screamed across the sky
and extremely close to our position the
first bomb dropped
the white building was reduced to wood
and debris in a nanosecond instantly
killing the sniper inside
fast forward a little bit at that point
we had two wounded afghans three wounded
americans and now two dead afghan
commandos
300 meters to the right of the compound
was another mud hut compound with
tall walls for protection and a large
open field big enough for helicopters to
land in
this was going to have to work because
we needed to get going we picked up and
quickly moved to our new location
and started calling a dust off which was
our call sign
a radio call sign for medical evacuation
so now you move into this bigger
compound
and you're preparing to get helicopters
in there to get the wounded and dead out
of there
you go over to bismullah i calmly asked
him if he knew where abe was
abe was next to me when we started
fighting he said
and then he jumped into the ditch near
the foot bridge at the last compound we
cleared
okay now i had a starting point but we
couldn't move or go near that area of
the village
the enemy was too well dug in every time
we poked our heads above
the near road we got lit up by the
taliban
somehow i had to get abe i was not
leaving him behind
i had an afghan commando pointing to the
footbridge saying another commando was
there with abe
that meant two wounded guys now which
also meant i would need more help
our air force jtac said he had a plan to
keep the taliban's head down
while we sprinted for the footbridge
i'll call the apaches
to fly in front of your movement and
shoot the [ __ ] out of everything ahead
of you guys
i like the way that sounded
little cover and move with the
helicopters
at the same time we were putting
together our two-minute game plan
the team sergeant stopped us we can't
risk you going down there to get those
guys he said too much enemy fire
well we're not leaving them behind i
said my team sergeant wasn't happy with
my answer but he knew what we had to do
i spoke up again if we leave without
them we could go we could have a mutiny
on our hands with the afghans
we have to go no one gets left behind
the team sergeant looked at us knowing
this was something that must happen
okay we'll go he said this was going to
be an american-led recovery operation
why the afghan commandos wouldn't go
recover their own guys was beyond me
if an american had been left behind we
would go to hell and back for our to get
our brothers out dead or alive
the jtac interrupted the discussion
stating the apaches were inbound
to do a gun run on enemy positions we
needed to use cover
this cover as our chance to move
here they come everyone ready the jtac
asked it was go time
the sounds of the large caliber bullets
echoed off the compound walls as the
apaches opened fire blanketing the area
with 30 millimeter rounds frankie our
jtac
our team sergeant and i sprinted down
the road toward the area
where we assumed abe and the mission
missing commando were
as we ran like hell in the direction of
the footbridge we took on small arms
fire but nothing compared to what
it could have been if those apaches
weren't helping us
the closer i got to the footbridge
though the more i prepared myself for
what i might see
leading up to the bridge the terrain
shifted upwards slightly making it hard
to see what was in the ditch i was
almost to the footbridge when i looked
down
there floating lifeless in the water at
the bottom of the ditch
was abe his body was sprawled out
with a blood soaked bandage around his
pelvic area
abe had attempted to stop the bleeding
himself but i knew that pelvic wounds
were almost impossible to treat without
proper
medical help abe had bled out so much
that the muddy water in the ditch had
turned bright red my friend was dead and
i could not save him
a taliban sniper had perfectly placed
three rounds into his pelvis
oh abe they finally got you
as i got to his body in the ditch
frankie was providing covering fire
while the team sergeant and i attempted
to pull abe out
lifting a lifeless body out of a six
foot muddy ditch was especially
difficult
adding to the difficulties was the fact
that ave's body was covered in blood
which made him extremely slippery to
hold on to we couldn't get a good grip
on him
and struggled to carry his body up to
dry ground
i became more and more drenched in abe's
blood and even got some of his blood in
my mouth a taste
that's forever etched in my mind finally
after
giving it everything we had we freed abe
from his watery grave
but the smells the tastes and everything
about that moment still haunt me to this
day
kind of kind of it's i mean
not only does it say a lot about the
american
soldier and the american fighting man
that eu4
go down to recover the body of these
afghans also obviously says a lot about
the afghans
who don't go
to go and recover their own people um
but that's you know to me it's a lot of
it just has to do with the value of
human life that we have as americans
like we see
we we value human life more
and the bond that we have is so strong
and it's just it's a it's a real
tribute to the american soldier
that you're you're going you're risking
your life and your friends are risking
your lives
your lives as americans to go and
basically you know that these guys are
dead i mean that's your suspicion
you know but you're still not going to
leave these guys behind
no one gets left behind
so
you get you get abe out of the trench
and you you basically you find a ladder
that
that you use as a stretcher you put him
on this thing on this ladder
you're carrying him into the compound as
you're carrying them into the compound
there's afghan commandos that are just
standing there watching you struggle
yeah back to the book don't just stand
there [ __ ] help us i screamed at the
commandos but they stood there like
statues we continued on the landing zone
to wait for the helicopter
i was carrying i was helping carrie abe
carry abe on the makeshift gurney when i
saw the helicopter hovering over it it
finally hit me my buddy was really dead
my heart sank when the helicopter
touched down i helped load
abe on to the last flight he would ever
take i reached out and grabbed his
lifeless hand as the helicopter lifted
off from the ground to take him away
yes abe was gone but we had recovered
his body
so that his family could give him a
proper burial a true warrior's funeral
if the taliban had recovered his body
they would have desecrated it
instead we did right by him
as american fighting men and women we
have one belief
we will fight and die for no one gets
left
behind
yeah and you know in the book you go
into a little bit about
both abe and bismullah who you knew
well and their backgrounds what kind of
guys they were
you know the the what they had
volunteered to do
right and you know like as i'm sitting
here calling you crazy
for wanting to go back and find ieds if
you're
if you're part of the afghan team guess
what guess how long your deployment
lasts
forever right so these guys are out
there hanging it out there
and you know you had that bond with them
and then you
stayed true to that bond yep
what was the what was the i mean you
know obviously shortly after this you
you end up getting the rest of the team
out
what was the total losses for that day
um that day we ended up with four
americans wia
eight afghans kia and 12 afghans wa
so it was it was pretty bad day
how big was the force going in we have
conflicting reports
the last report i remember seeing is we
killed over 400 taliban
now aircraft killed over 400 taliban we
you know personally probably you know 10
20 at small arms
but that's still a pretty big force but
um
over 400. how many guys did you have
total how many afghans how big was the
afghan commando unit
um we hundred and i think about 120
afghans and then an oda and an odb so
about 25 americans about 120 um afghans
how
how much longer were you in country
after that operation
um that had actually just started the
deployment off so we still had another
um i think i'd say five more months
and what was the what was the rest of
the deployment like uh
it was it was back to um just trying to
trying to chase you know chase that
elusive combat
again but nothing uh nothing came even
close to touching uh baglin and did they
did they throw you back in because you
your original purpose on that deployment
was more of work in the
intel side yep did you get moved back
into that and that's kind of what you
spent most of the deployment
yeah deployment doing i did yeah i was i
was moved back into the
into the intel role of it and i would um
you know i would constantly try and
create work and find myself on missions
and whatnot
but um yeah i was back you know doing
the doing those reports
i'm gonna fast forward a little bit um
to
you're heading home when our 2016 tour
of duty was over in july
our team boarded a c-17 at bagram
airfield and flew west until we landed
at eglin air force base
near pensacola florida following a fuel
stop at ramstein air base in germany
we basically hopped from the dangers of
the afghan
from the dangers of afghanistan to
tranquil florida within 24 hours
the quickest i ever returned home i
still had afghanistan dirt underneath my
fingernails
i didn't realize that i had suffered
traumatic brain injury
during the fire fight where the 500
pound bomb had landed just 17
meters from my position
binge drinking on weekends became the
norm for me
fast forward in a little bit including
consumption of a lot of beer at home i
could easily clear 12 to 15 miller
lights in an evening
and you know you you again it's really
good because in this book you go through
some of the details of what's happening
when you come home from deployment you
know you have that kind of
what is it a little empty feeling that
we get something like that
and you're trying to fill it up you're
trying to figure out you know what this
is
how to adjust back to
being in florida or wherever you're
going to be
so you're doing
you're doing the path which is easily
available to us when we come home which
is drinking
fighting uh causing problems um
a little road rage activity you're with
dawn and are you married to don at this
point
uh no we got buried in 18. so you got
your girlfriend dawn
and you're you're like driving and
you're with dawn
and i'm gonna go to the book here the
dude suddenly turned into this is oh
yeah he cuts you off
right driving and you get your road rage
on and you follow him
what kind of vehicle are you driving i
was driving uh tundra
okay jack uh so you're driving your
tundra
this dude suddenly turned into a
driveway and ran into the house i slid
into the curb and put my
truck in park i was about to run after
him when
dawn grabbed my arm what are you doing
she asked are you gonna chase him down
beat him up and then what what if
we've got guns in the house what makes
you think he doesn't have them this is
stupid what's going on with you right
now
she had a point i let out a huge breath
of air which dialed back the adrenaline
surging through my body [ __ ] this i
mumbled as i got back into the truck
i eased away from the curb and turned
homeward
for the next 10 minutes neither of us
said a word my mind was locked on this
thought
you need to get your temper under
control damn it
i was a green beret that meant i was a
professional and flipping the switch
between civilian life and being in a war
zone
was the professional thing to do
yet here i was acting like a bully if
someone did something i didn't like
i took some active measures over the
next few days and weeks
i opened up to my friend mike valkyr how
do you say his name yeah valk
i opened up to my friend my friend mike
valk tyler and frankie about some of my
struggles
it turned out i wasn't alone after
sharing my innermost thoughts with
frankie
he said he was going through the same
issues as me finally
someone gets it and this is where you
started kind of getting control though
nothing happened overnight
i slowly got my [ __ ] under control my
anger issues at times were still an open
question but i started to focus on what
triggered me
which helped me ratchet my aggression
way down
um yeah i kind of i kind of uh spoiler
alerted on the
on the marriage thing but luckily i
didn't spoil much because in a very
romantic fashion in
applebee's parking lot you asked dawn if
she would marry you
yeah uh you got married
um you get cleared you do another seven
month deployment
to afghanistan in august 2018
ends in march of 2019.
you say in the book here in a few words
my last deployment to afghanistan was
boring and cold
you you detail some of these missions
you also say that
boring has tons of upside for coming
back with all your limbs which is good
and you did make it home from that
deployment
with all your limbs but and you did make
it home and
obviously as we know not everybody does
and i want to close out this book
you know you detail some more
information and
um but i want to close out the book
in the actually in the acknowledgements
when you address the fact that not
everyone comes home
and you say last i want to point out the
men who
epitomize heroic courage and whom i look
up to for strength
ben harrow will
liles and levi rogers yes
those guys are wounded uh yes uh levi
he um he was in a um max pro or
rg that hit an ied everyone died but him
in it so that was chief rogers ben was
my team leader
when i got hit and then on the 2012
deployment he stepped on an ied
lost both of his legs and then will
liles
he was one of my friends that i went
through the course with and
this basically the same time frame that
i stepped on my ied he stepped on his
and lost both of his legs
so you say these three men are the
definition of what it means to overcome
astronomical odds to go through hell and
back only to come out stronger on the
other side
i will forever be grateful for the
lessons i learned from them
as well as their strength and
determination in putting aside their
catastrophic injuries
to show me the true value of life
they remind me that no matter what life
throws at you
or how bad you think you have it you can
always pick yourself
up off the ground and kick life in the
ass
for the men in heaven keeping a watchful
eye on us
i salute you may god hold you close
and give you the comfort you all deserve
until we meet again i will do my best to
live the life
you all embodied while you are here
still
walking among us
so that's that
like i said this is a powerful book um
and
we're reading this very small percentage
of it
um i definitely recommend go out get
this book read the full story
it's just powerful and it's a powerful
tribute you know that powerful tribute
at the end to
all these guys and it's just it's just
amazing when you think about
um the sacrifices that have been made by
by the service men and women in this
country has been just
we should nev we can never ever allow
that to be forgotten and i think this
book
is a is a personal account of
some of those sacrifices
what so what's going on now
so i actually um i retired from the army
in uh in january of 2000
or 2020. and was that was that 20 years
uh yeah 21 and some change and then
within a week i was back in afghanistan
as a as a contractor
so i gave my time about i gave myself
about five days to
celebrate retirement then i was i was
back at it and that's what you're doing
now you're doing contracting
yes and you're continuing to go how how
long are you going on deployments now
um so these are these are four month
deployments um
uh chromavirus had a little something to
do with the last one so we stayed longer
but um the next one i have coming up is
that will be a four-monther and then
we'll kind of re-address
readdress you know what's going on in
afghanistan and whatnot like that
what um you talk about in the book but i
didn't read through it
at what point did you start writing the
book
so the book actually um it started off
as
as therapy and when i came back from the
16 trip
the road rage incident was one but there
was there's multiple other ones
but um and and so i actually
you know i remember going to a therapist
um
army you know count our counselor
therapist whatever they're called
and he was kind of going down his list
and i remember asking him is like
what's my name and i saw his eyes had to
go up to the top right hand corner
and i was like i'm done here so i
started
you know i you know our chaplains and
group are very close with us
and um i i remember um talking to one of
them just
and my biggest my biggest issue was like
all three of us we could be
we could be sitting at a bar drinking a
beer and talking about
you know things and what we deal with
and whatnot like that and then
you go home to your family you go home
to yours and i go home to mine
and it's dead air it was it was talked
about but nothing was really like
taken off your chest and so our chaplain
is like have you ever thought about
writing
i said no i haven't i majored in
you know english in like the third grade
or zombies no i've never thought about
writing
so the 2017 deployment um so i went
to afghanistan 16 17 18.
um and then back in 1920
19 2019 and 20.
so pretty much since 16 i've been in
afghanistan every year
and um and in the 17 trip i
i just remember just needing
to to just get stuff off my chest
and and i remember i was you know i was
i was in my little uh
little living area and i just opened up
my laptop and just started typing
and typing and it just and it felt good
because i was
i was taking i was taking these these
these um
i'll call them items but i was taking
these items that that had been bothering
me for years or
been or just anything and i wasn't
just talking about it and it was dead
air not to be
you know having to be readdressed again
but i was putting it on something else
that was tangible
a word document and so i could come back
to that word document anytime i wanted
and it actually felt like you know i was
i was taking this
off of my chest and i was putting it
somewhere
that was actually tangible now it was
something
and it felt great and that's and that's
when i said oh
writing therapy gotcha makes sense now
but and then from that um came the book
so yeah you know it's uh i always talk
about using
detachment is is what you you have to do
that as a person you have to get you
have to detach from your emotions you
can't
get all cr look i'm not saying you need
to leave all your emotions totally
behind
but i'm saying you have to detach from
them somewhat
and what's cool about writing and this
is
i was trying to figure out what you
meant by this so it's just dead air and
i was like oh wait a second i get it
when you write something down you are
you are
actually detaching from it right you get
to see those words are coming out
they're going somewhere else now you're
looking at those words
and so it gives you a an actual physical
form of
detachment from the thoughts that you
have from the feelings that you have
from the emotions that you have
and then you can read them you can read
them from a distance and you can
understand them better
and then as you continue to work through
the writing that you're doing and
it it's another way to reprocess it
and had you ever i i actually don't
think i think i've i guess i have heard
the term writing therapy
but like i guess it's a thing huh i've
never heard about it before until that
point yeah but did you just make that up
yourself
or had you think of her i so
when i had when when i started typing
um writing therapy that was that was
purely what i just thought it was but i
think i've heard of it before
like i do think it's a thing yeah i
think it's a thing i think it's a thing
too
we're gonna have to find out if not
we're gonna have to trademark it
you should trade market uh maybe that's
why i'm just
writing books all the time just
providing therapy for myself
and so then what did you do how did you
get the book published
so i went yeah that that was kind of a
funny situation so
i basically i had all of these notes or
not notes but i had all these
um pages of my life 500 and some odd
and i had a couple you know i i had
reorganized it to kind of like the
organization
in the book and i had a couple people
like frankie
and mike read it and they're like this
is me
like yeah that's that's me and so i said
you
you know you should make this a book and
so you know i did the
google and and you get these you get
these [ __ ] that'll take you for your
money so i lost about five grand with uh
with a fake ghostwriter or whatever i
was like man
so finally i got a hold of um you know
my buddy said hey just
google military authors and send them an
email
and i i can't remember how many but this
lady named lynn
vincent um she's here in san diego but
she contacted me back
she said hey you know i got i got a guy
that yeah
he'd take a look at it for you so mike
yorkie who's another san diego guy
um i sent it to him and he's you know he
read it he's like
yeah this this needs to be a book and so
mike and i painstakingly
sentence by sentence went back and forth
over you know florida to san diego over
the period of a year
creating a document to send to the dod
for review
dod review went through good to go
no no redactions and then
mike had a good buddy of his who's an
agent named greg johnson and greg he was
able to
um yeah he he sent the proposal
yeah to hachette book group and
they were like yeah so that's that's
basically
what got that started um i
yeah i was i was in afghanistan most of
the time but
it's yeah i still i still couldn't
believe it and the first time
my i was in afghanistan when my book
released july
7th of this year and i remember this uh
this this kid came up to i call him a
kid because you know
i'm 42 and he's he's a young private
and he said hey um can i ask you a
question sir it's like yeah he goes did
you uh did you write a book i was like
no i didn't write a book um
and he goes huh that's funny and he held
the book and he goes because this kind
of looks like he's like give me that
book you know son of a [ __ ]
you know like i'm not here to promote a
book i'm here to do a job
and then i was like well let me see that
book and that's the first time i ever
touched my book
while you were on the ground in
afghanistan yeah
so what's the future hold um another
deployment
uh but my wife and i actually strangely
enough we
are going down the adoption route now oh
right now yep
so um ied kind of made it to where
having kids is is going to be an issue
but adoption is not
so we're we're starting that whole
process right now and
it's very murky
so so weird but you know we'll we'll get
all that done and hopefully um
within the next year uh we'll uh open up
our home and uh
give you know give a little one a a
great life
and so that's yep that's what we're
going on and uh
yeah i just i don't know other other
than that just kind of living life and
riding the lightning and and uh
slowly trying to trying to build up
people around me making up for years of
destructiveness so man uh
look we've i've had you over here for
three over three hours um
people can find you where can they find
you so i um
actually have a website it's uh ryan m
hendrickson.com
and then um they
yeah i'm on i'm on instagram at um tip
of the spear
rmh um but yeah the the website that has
the links to
everything so it's so it's ryan m
hendrickson.com
yes right on man
awesome echo you got anything else no i
don't actually
that's a shocking moment yeah kind of
yeah that's a shocking moment
any uh any clothing thoughts closing
thoughts ryan
yeah i mean we talked a lot about my dad
but i
i it's you know the guy's a hero um and
some
some good advice you know definitely
that has
helped change my life around and then
you know like we were talking about with
don
my wife um you know we had we had dated
since 2008
and yeah in 2018 when we got married
it was it was kind of like like hey i'm
gonna
i'm gonna tell you what's gonna happen
there guy we are getting married before
you go back to afghanistan
i was like man what if i say no she's
like you're not
you're we're getting married like this
is happening so okay so
but yeah she's she's a stud um and i'm
blessed
so but there's yeah there's a lot of
people that have done some
you know amazing things in my life and i
do
um you know i think a lot of these
different organizations out there like
the green beret foundation
and i know the seals have one and the
marines have one but
they really do um one of the things that
i would have to say that
i'm most proud of because i see it from
my dad is my dad got closure on the
vietnam war
seeing how i was taken care of and
the military has done a very good job
at um taking care of us you know of of
guys that we
we come back change forever and there's
still a lot of work to do
but um i just yeah there's
it's it's good it's good and um i
definitely i
you know i'm proud to you know i'm proud
to be a soldier i'm proud to serve my
country
and i'm i'm proud of everybody that has
and i just
i think we're we're on the right path so
awesome man well thanks for coming on
here to
to you know share this story and it's
it's quite a story
uh and obviously any much more important
thanks for your service
thanks for your sacrifice in in the navy
in the air force and in the army uh
thanks for being out there thanks for
keeping evil at bay
thanks for protecting your brothers
and your comrades and most of all thanks
for protecting us in this great nation
appreciate it greatest nation on earth
amen
and with that ryan hendrickson has left
the building
uh to go and carry on
and live the best life that he can
and it certainly seems like we should do
the same
i agree echo any
recommendations suggestions on how we
can live
the best life we can what do you got i
would say overall there's a lot of
things
we can do so this might seem like an
obvious one
because we talk about it every single
time but i'm going to say it again
oh yeah i'm going to say like you are
anyway we're working out i i suggest or
should i say recommend reading too
i was about to say we don't really talk
about reading that much but technically
we do
talk about reading a lot well we're
reading i mean i'm
literally reading all the time that's
what i'm saying yeah so um
yes so boom we're doing a bunch of
things we need improvement things not
we need generative not degenerative
for lack of
anyway while we're working out we take a
beating your body takes a beating i just
got over bursitis quickly by the way
again by the way i narrowed down what
causes my bursitis and i heal weakness
let's say the limitations of my body how
about that okay from time to time
weakness
anyway we don't want to worry about our
joints
while we're taking those beatings with
our workouts it's part of life
but we don't want to worry about that
kind of stuff so good news jocko fuel so
we take our supplementation for our
joints which is
i'm just going to start with this which
is joint warfare super krill oil
it'll sort your joints right out so you
don't have to worry about them
also immunity right that's a big thing
getting sick like these are things that
like we don't want to have to worry
about
joint immunity so for immunity we got
vitamin d also
cold war take these
yeah if you don't want to worry about
immunity definitely take these
yes sir also what do we got uh
discipline
kind of kind of like a not even really a
supplement i mean technically
supplementation
but you want to go kind of lifestyle
lifestyle kind of a lifestyle thing
and actually now that we're so now that
we're thinking about you know the way
ryan used the term lifestyle it could be
used negative
because i'm thinking now if you think
about the la the joint warfare is a
lifestyle
krill oil super acryl is a lifestyle
yeah
oh yeah yeah fully you should make
vitamin d a lifestyle that should be
part of your life
it's the way you live cold war the way
you live
why would you why would you not do that
there's not
there's no reason to not be living this
lifestyle
there's zero reason this will make you
better yeah that's that's that
same thing with the discipline yep yeah
it's true
so discipline is one of those when you
first came out with it
i was like yeah cool like cool i'll take
it but you didn't really sometimes you
didn't really
understand i didn't really understand i
am
a full understanding at this time i
think
uh so yes that is a lifestyle so this
one has three
methodologies of deployment for lack of
a better way of putting it
boom discipline powder pre-workout
that's my i'm saying my little routine
my little lifestyle
if you will pre-workout is the powder
discipline go the pills i don't take i
just don't have to
well that's me because i'm going to talk
and i need that little
different lifestyle exactly right a
little hitter
but the discipline go cans energy drink
that's just like a real energy
that's like a treat okay look i don't
want to group this in with energy drink
because we know what that means it's
actually we know what that means
this isn't an energy drink it's real
energy a healthy energy drink
it's definitely healthy somebody asked
me the other day like on uh on
the social media platform
is this healthy imagine being asked if
it's healthy and i get to say yes it is
it's actually healthy yeah also i'm sure
you had that feeling like kind of like
tim kennedy had when you asked him if he
was allowed to shoot his guns in his
backyard
oh yeah remember when you ask him that
he's yeah he's like i'm not even gonna
justify that question with an answer
it's kind of like that you kind of feel
that only because you know though but
here's the thing that's a good question
but
it is a good question and also it's a
good question because
the chances that you go through the
effort to make actually make something
and spend the time and effort and money
to make something that's actually good
for you the chances of that
are rare yeah but we did it we did it
uh also got mulk
which is also good for you in 47
different ways
yeah one of them being protein the other
one being tasty
yeah so this so i have a thing right in
my household
lifestyle whatever with the kids they
don't get dessert
during the week these are only on the
weekends
so every once in a while like when the
smashed
smashing pumpkin malt came out i make a
big deal out of it you know
do this thing say hey you guys want to
taste this or whatever this can be
like the dessert but not not today it's
like a thursday or whatever
tomorrow so i build the hype you see
what i'm saying
next day they're all excited we get to
try that new thing you guys got or
whatever
so make it up give it to them
of course they love it but you got the
extra hype and then on top of that it's
like good for you
i'm saying so i tricked them so now in
the future hey this is a long game we're
playing the long game over here
in the future i'll make them think i'm
in a better mood than normal during the
week i'll be like hey
and i'll be the good dad give them
dessert during the during the
the week and they get the health
benefits i'm actually giving you
a solid 94 grade on that
good job man long term yeah tight i like
that i like how you played that whole
thing you played the psychological you
played the human nature
yeah you know you we we could call it
manipulation but we won't because you're
doing something that's good for them
for everybody i see what you i like it
exactly right so yes
thank you charles jocko belittle
my son knows brian littlefield's actual
name
refers to him by his first and last name
when he sees when he's
taking more or drinking milk eating the
uh
all right here's a little inside tip
the milk bar is like he'll send me the
samples you know
so have you got the latest ones yes
i got a few of them uh my son ate him
yeah and and that's part of the reason
why he'll be like hey call brian
littlefield
to call him and tell him to send more or
tell him thank you or all this stuff
anyway so yes thank you guys for for
creating this
this is helping us on many many levels
if you want to get any of this stuff
you can get it at origin maine.com
you can get it at the vitamin shop
nationwide you can actually get it on
amazon
prime and if you're in florida
if you're in florida go to a wawa
in florida and just go clear out the
shelves just go clear them out why
because
of go discipline go and the can is there
we're trying to
it's beyond infiltrate but we start we
have to start we have to start with
infiltration it starts in florida
so if you're down there go to wawa clear
clean out the shelves
clean them out and then we'll get you
the whole east coast then we'll be out
west coast and pretty soon we'll be
everywhere you go
you'll be able to get some you'll be
able to get that
little hitter
and it's doing good that's the thing
it's doing good for us
for all of us who drink this it's doing
good for us yeah yeah because you can
land in
wisconsin hopefully in a little while
and be like oh cool i'm going into
any store and i'm going to get some go
yup yeah it's true
so yes origin maine.com speaking of
which has
jiu-jitsu geese made in america by the
way
other clothing items made in america by
the way
also american denim and boots
made in america again by the way which
is a big deal
oh it's a real big deal as far as
economy as far as like
what you're what the craftsmanship what
you're actually wearing like the whole
deal
as far as rebuilding the economy
and the manufacturing capabilities of
our nation
yes it's a big deal and you can help out
you can help that you can help that go
to origin maine.com
if you want something get something
speaking of getting something if you
want jocko has a store
called jocko store this is what this is
a discipline equals freedom
store this is what it is really okay
also it's a good store oh i see where
you're going
disciplining freedom which is good very
funny
anyway you want to represent while
you're on this path and the path is not
easy
some of us choose to represent while
we're on this path it feels good
this is where you go jocklestore.com uh
get you know get a shirt
a jacket a hat christmas is coming up
we got gift cards on there even yeah
i'll tell you what here's what's going
on with this let me give you a little
heads up
christmas is coming right now covid the
whole nine yards
there is a shortage of aircraft there's
a shortage of shipping personnel i'm
talking about
in the entire world we're not gonna be
able to ship what needs to get shipped
so if you wanna
if you want stuff don't wait
don't wait order it now yeah that's the
facts
yeah that's what i would say too and i'm
not just talking about jocko store i'm
talking about origin i'm talking about
amazon i'm talking about wherever you're
getting stuff sent from order it early
let's be
ahead of the power curve don't get
behind the power curve this ain't the
kind of year we're going to be like
december 22nd ordering my wife's gift
for christmas don't let it happen
yeah i got to keep that in mind by the
way now that you mentioned it but yeah
good
good tips for sure so but on the store
also like i said we have gift cards so
you don't got to worry about shipping
for that kind of stuff for the gift card
you just get it right it's like a
digital thing boom yeah you get the code
you get a boom boom boom easy money
yeah but if you're trading you
understand what i'm saying also what
else we have
is our jocko's t-shirt club
okay oh this is a good club this is
where you can get like if you're you
know
you can get a little bit more how should
i say
layered creative
light-hearted sometimes shirts
they're kind of like monthly
one-of-a-kind once we once
we pass the month we're not selling
those anymore so if you're part of the
club you get these kind of
these shirts can you if you if you if
you're in the club and there's a
shirt that came out before can you get
that sure probably as of right now no
okay
okay as of right now but you never know
every once in a while
it's kind of like man now down down was
really good so let's you know bring it
back or was maybe i don't know but as
right now afraid not sorry so yes uh
it's a
subscription-based situation so yeah
it's a t-shirt club so look into that if
you want that that's cool
if you want to support and you want to
be on the path while representing good
ones
that one very much so yes so
jackostore.com
also subscribe to this podcast if you
haven't already which is i don't know
it always feels weird saying not
subscribe but whatever
so yes you are if if you want to
subscribe
just know if you didn't know that you
can subscribe well there you go there's
other podcasts you can leave a review
yeah other podcasts we got the debrief
which is already inside this throughout
you're going to worry about
subscribing to that one but we also have
the jocko unraveling
jocko unraveling podcast daryl coupe and
i talking about
all kinds of crazy stuff all kinds of
crazy stuff on that grounded podcast
which we owe for your kid podcast which
your kid for is coming out so we're
working on that one we got a youtube
channel
if you want to see what echo charles
does
in his spare time
then you can check out the youtube
channel you can see what echo charles
looks like you can see what ryan
hendrickson looks like
because we put the whole podcast on
there and a bunch of
short clips of the podcast which
according to echo charles are
shareable yeah shareable shareable
yes and we can you know obviously we're
gonna you know in the in the spirit of
brevity
i think i use that right we're not going
to go into why that's so valuable
maybe we could and we don't need to but
yes little excerpts you want to share
with your friend boom you share the
excerpt all good
and let's face the fact some of the
excerpts have explosions
have fire have smoke have all kinds of
things that users lasers just those kind
of things
if you're into that kind of stuff which
one of the people that are speaking on
this podcast right now
is into yes sir maybe even two
yes so yeah youtube channel look at that
one um subscribe if you want to
also psychological warfare
if you know what that is that's that's
an album of tracks of jocko helping you
through moments of weakness if they may
arise in your life which i think
for most of us they do from time to time
so boom just check that out
and and if you want some visual
representation of that then you can go
to flipsidecampus.com
owned by my brother dakota meyer where
he makes awesome stuff
for you to look at to keep you on the
path we got a bunch of books
you mentioned reading earlier i also
concur that reading is important
first of all tip of the spear ryan
hendrickson
this book is just it's a great book all
kinds of good guidance i gave you 10
10 of it 5 of it today so check that out
about face by david hackworth i wrote
the forward to that
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual
you got the code the evaluation the
protocols you got the discipline equals
freedom field manual
uh look what are you gonna say is it
lame to say like this is a good book
gift book
it's kind of lame to say that but it's
also the truth
yeah it's not lame to say that the truth
is the truth is this is a this is a book
you can give to somebody as a gift and
you don't feel like
you don't feel like oh i was i was
wandering by the bookstore and yeah
oh i thought you might like this like
this isn't that book this is about like
hey i got you this and people are like
check so
get it this one goes freedom field
manual the new edition
way the warrior kid one two three and
guess what
weigh the warrior kid four once again if
you want to get this
book for christmas for your kids you
need to order it
like now way the warrior kid four
field manual mikey and the dragons
that's a good one for the kids
extreme ownership of the dichotomy of
leadership
the the og books written with my brother
leif babin
we have a consulting company called
echelon front where we solve problems
through leadership we have ef
online where you can actually ask me any
question you want and i will be
sitting there virtually on a computer
live talking to you and answering your
question so go to efonline.com for that
we've got the muster 2020. this is the
only muster that we're doing in 2020.
if you want to learn about leadership if
you want to get
granular information about the
principles that we talk about all the
time
come to the muster dallas texas december
3rd and 4th
extremeownership.com for details ef
overwatch if you want to hire someone
that understands the principles that we
talk about all the time that has
experienced tested leadership experience
from the military we'll go to
eforewatch.com
if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families
check out mark lee's mom's charity
organization
mama lee it's called america's mighty
warriors and it's at america's
mightywarriors.org you can go there if
you want to donate or if you want to get
involved
and listen if you're into misery
personal
self-inflicted misery and you want more
of it
you want more of my unremarkable remarks
or you need more of echoes chaotic
commentary then you can find us on the
interwebs
on twitter instagram which echo will
only refer to as
the gram and on facebook echo is
adequate charles i am at jocko willing
ryan hendrickson you can find him tip of
the spear on instagram tip of the
spear rmh on twitter he's tip of the
spear 42
facebook is ryan hendrickson and he's
also got ryan hendrickson.com
and thanks once again to ryan for coming
on
for sharing this story what an
incredible story and obviously
thank you ryan for your service and for
your sacrifice and for taking care
of your your comrades on the battlefield
and in taking care of all of us and
protecting all of us and thanks to all
the military personnel out there in
every branch of service in the army
navy the air force the marine corps and
the coast guard
thank you for doing the same protecting
us
and that also goes for our first
responders here at home
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol
secret service all of you
thanks for protecting us here at home
and everyone else out there like ryan
said in his book
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
but that doesn't happen on its own you
have to
choose to get stronger
take control of your life take
responsibility
for your actions something i call
taking ownership extreme ownership and
yes do that go out there
every day and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out